We're live bobcat.
Goldthwait what the fuck are you doing
going on?
Big Foot convention and then a moth man
convention.
We know now you're ranking bad guy.
You're a grown man.
I,
uh,
I just went to see where the month man
was or how bad.
It wasn't a moth man convention.
No,
I was about,
uh,
at the,
I was in the,
at the Ohio bigfoot conference,
which was less than two hours away from
point pleasant West Virginia where the
moth man appeared.
Uh,
and uh,
when I was talking with some of this,
you know,
big foot researchers,
I said,
you do that with air quotes when you say
that the researchers,
I was talking to him and I said,
hey,
you know,
we're really close to where the moth man
was.
And they're like,
well,
the Mosman is not real.
Oh,
so do they silly that?
No,
no.
Well,
some did.
You know,
that's the thing.
Zimmerman categories of,
of uh,
big foot,
uh,
people,
there's people who are self aware.
There's people who are,
who seem pretty regular and you don't,
that's the thing.
You go to these conventions and,
and um,
you have this idea of what a person is,
who believes that there's an 800 pound
wood ape out there.
And then,
um,
when you get to know them,
you realize that,
um,
they're really fucking weird.
Yeah,
no,
I'm kidding.
But there is that,
there is a lot of that.
There's a lot of that,
but I,
I have to say,
uh,
I love them.
I had a great time.
Uh,
and uh,
it was really fun.
It was great.
I've had some people that I talked to.
What was the professor from?
Uh,
Belgium?
Yes.
Professor Meldrum,
who's a really interesting guy for sure.
Who is,
do you know who he is?
Pretty prominent.
Yeah.
And the big foot community who's a very
rational,
reasonable person that told me he would
cut his pinky off to know the truth.
Ah,
hoping.
And you said,
you know what,
I can do it.
I'll do it with an arrow.
I'm more fascinated about,
I mean,
I'm sure your listeners are more,
you know,
over it,
but it,
about you going out and hunting a bear
with an arrow.
What's interest eating them.
It's really interesting.
What kind of,
what is it?
What does it taste good?
They taste really good.
Like,
like,
uh,
like I,
the way I describe it as like a deer
fucked a pig.
It's,
it's kind of almost taking,
uh,
the,
tofurky to a new level.
But I,
uh,
you know,
my brother,
uh,
he was,
he passed away.
My brother was a,
uh,
um,
I kind of say a hunter,
but he was actually a poacher.
My brother,
when he passed away,
uh,
people said,
hey,
can,
um,
can I have your doe permit?
And I was like,
what?
He's like,
my brother had been getting a dope
permit in my name
for like 20 years.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
He had all these forge dope.
It's,
he shot animals all year long.
He didn't read the game.
Warden was bused into his home with a
bolt cutter,
you know,
lock cutters and a crack open his
freezer and there'd be all this game out
of season.
Oh Man.
He,
uh,
yeah,
but you know,
he ate it.
Right.
But he,
uh,
yeah,
yeah.
He didn't abide by the rules?
Well,
no,
it did not abide by all anyone's roles
is his funeral was uh,
it was awesome and Eclectic,
but there's two things.
Someone should have given me a heads up.
Well,
first of all,
a couple of the pallbearers were in
Cammo.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
a serious hunter,
hunter,
biker.
Where do you live?
A central New York and Syracuse and then
Rome and around.
But you know,
I love my brother,
but he was wild and,
and then the other thing,
they probably should have given me a
heads up that it's friend a little.
Ricky was one of the pallbearers.
Yeah,
he was,
uh,
I just like,
I don't want to use the word,
I was going to say like a Munchkin.
Good,
safe.
I didn't want to use the other word.
I mean he wasn't even a tiny person.
It's a little person.
He wasn't a dwarf,
but cause you know,
he was regular size almost.
I don't know.
He was tiny,
but he didn't look,
you know what I mean?
I get it.
But nobody said ricky was going to be a
Paul bear or giving me a heads up.
So I looked down the end of the church.
He's in the middle,
on one side of the casket and then
middle.
Yeah.
And I said to my daughter,
go,
looks like Ricky's riding a subway.
My Dad,
he's like,
I think he just got air freezes going on
about how am I brother Tom?
He loved the outdoors and he loved
animals.
And then I went on after the breeze,
I go farther.
I don't want to be,
you know,
impolite.
But my,
my brother liked to kill animals.
There's a lot of deer right now in the
woods going,
whoo,
whoo.
Upstate New York.
So very dear rich place.
People don't have a lot of tolerance.
So those animals,
a lot of them,
that car accident,
well,
there's a lot and there's more now than
when I was a kid.
But when,
uh,
you know,
Tony Vee,
Boston,
so tony,
I went up to visit my brother.
I had given him some money to buy some
windows for his house.
It's a long story,
but he lived,
this is what he's really out in the
woods.
And uh,
we pull up to his yard and there's just,
um,
there's just corn growing like there's
no rows.
It's his whole front and backyard of
corn.
Like there's like psycho corn,
there's no rows or anything.
Right.
And uh,
and Tony didn't know my brother and he
comes out and he goes,
hey,
what's,
what's up with the corn?
He's like,
ah,
as far as the dear bobby,
you know,
he's like,
and Tony's like,
oh,
you help them through the winter.
It's like,
no,
I'm going to blast them.
My brother actually made us,
he just switched your house?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's so fucked up.
And I go,
I'm in the matthew,
even the new windows cracked and I go,
tell me what happened to this new
windows you have bob,
you had a little problem with recoil.
So my brother and we sit on the toilet
and shoot deer.
Swear to God,
swear to God.
I'm sure he's probably burned in one,
two.
You can't take any shit.
You want to go hunt and you know,
meet me in the kitchen,
you know,
and then then one time him,
his family and his friends got really
high and they,
they just turn this a station wagon and
doing convertible with the Helios
torches and they would use that.
That was their hunting will be and shoot
out of it.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
I wrapped this part of the story,
so,
so tony,
he's going,
you'd brothers certify,
but like you said,
we're going around my brother.
So he goes,
Tony,
and I get back in the car and we're
heading to the car and Tony sees this
woodchuck across the street until he
goes,
what is that?
And [inaudible] to chucky with chuck.
And then,
um,
and then we're not even down the end of
the driveway and we have Tony's going.
I just figured that would shut yo,
man,
that would just dead.
You drop the dime on that.
We'll check you fingered that would
check that.
What is his family is going to go papa,
papa coming through the door.
Yeah,
my brother,
uh,
you know,
God rest his soul.
He was a wild man while he was a sheet
metal worker and uh,
you know,
he rode bikes for a long time.
He was always a,
you know,
there was always our home when I was a
kid was like,
you know,
the movie mask and it was just always
bikes.
Motor clubs will come over to the house
and keg parties and stuff like that.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It helped me to go to the big foot
conference.
No.
So that's what I grew up with.
You know,
guys name like low life and all these
guys.
And My mother was great because they
would come in,
you know,
uh,
my mother was sweet because she would
know,
only know their,
you know,
their biker names.
Yeah.
And he's like,
hello shithead.
Yeah,
exactly.
It would be like low life.
Showed up with a shirt that said
Harley's the best fucked her ass.
And he's like low life,
not in my house.
So I was a GE and they had turned the
shirt or not.
Yeah.
So I grew up with bikers and it wasn't
until later on I realized,
Oh,
you know,
some bikers aren't Rad.
You know what I mean?
Like you know,
oh I see.
I mean like I'm,
I saw him,
I'd be like,
Hey,
how are you?
Like you're a nice guy,
so useless to me.
They're always nice being like cool,
fun.
And my brother had a lot of clout in
that world.
So yes,
everyone was cool.
But then later on I was like,
oh some of these guys aren't so awesome.
But so basically bikers are like bears
at the dump.
Like they look cool but stay in the car
or New York case.
I had an idea that I forgot.
I know and you're not going to go with
it,
but it reminds me of a,
I was,
cause I was reading people's tweets in
there.
I asking what am I up to next,
you know,
for the next movie.
But there was a movie I wrote that I
even thought of you,
but I know you don't act in everything
and I don't even walk on it.
Yeah,
you won't do it.
But I it is it,
I won't do it.
Well I don't know,
but it's not an alcoholic clown.
No,
no,
no.
It's a gay billy Jack Movies.
Cause Cause,
cause I love Billy Jack.
Come on man.
This would be perfect for,
you don't have to fuck anybody to blind.
Well it's,
I'll tasteful,
but it's like I'm from the guy who shot
a baby on camera and a movie.
It's all tasteful.
So,
um,
no,
it's um,
uh,
I was,
I was married at the time and I said to
my wife,
I go,
I'm tired of being broke.
I'm going to write a genre picture.
I Love Billy Jack Movies when I was a
kid.
Uh,
so I started writing it and I was about
40 pages in and she's like,
how's it going?
I'm like,
well,
he's gay now.
And she goes,
so I'm just going to keep renting.
We're not going to get a home.
I got,
yeah,
pretty much.
So,
uh,
and uh,
and I,
and I was talking to Gus van Zant.
I said,
I want to write a,
uh,
an action film.
You know,
like if you were 13 year old gay boy be
the coolest movie you saw besides the
300,
you know,
and so,
so,
so he's,
it's just classic Billy Jack,
you know,
he goes into the buyer,
he's tried to have a drink,
redneck town.
He's like,
hey fag.
I'm going to have to ask you to stop
using that word.
He's like,
Oh God,
what are you going to do?
Well,
I'm going to shatter his knee cap and
I'm going to,
I'm going to shatter your wind pipe.
Or,
you know,
it goes through the whole list and you
want to know something.
There's not a goddamn thing you can do
about it.
And then it says,
and he does.
And then he goes back,
he kicks ass.
It goes back to the bar,
finishes that drink that he was trying
to drink and puts it down.
And he says to the bartering,
cause he's a decent man.
Is there a decent place for a man to
stay in this town?
And then it cuts and he's in bed with
that dude.
Oh God.
Come on Joe.
Come on.
Well,
I mean,
look at brokeback mountain.
it was essentially like a cowboy romance
twist to me.
It had all the elements of her,
like a regular cowboy romance.
And I wanted this to be like,
to me the political,
yeah,
right.
It was triumph.
I don't even know you had a trial.
Yeah.
Well,
but I was thinking about,
do you remember Jay Leno?
Did you remember to Jack and Jay Leno
would wear it's beautiful flower.
It makes me want to go nuts.
So,
uh,
but I,
I wanted them to have the bike that,
uh,
you remember then King Bronson,
you're younger than me.
You wouldn't remember it then came
Brian.
Yeah,
he was bad ass.
He,
he,
uh,
was kind of the forerunner to,
to,
to Billy Jack.
It was a TV show and uh,
yeah,
he,
uh,
there you go.
He was,
uh,
a reporter that got fed up and then he
just drove around and kicked as this.
See,
I'm going to have the triangle,
but it's not going to be the,
yeah.
It's not going to be that.
That's a sweet bike.
Yeah.
Right in that rat.
But I'm just going to have,
but he's got the Illuminati on his
painting.
He's got the aluminum.
I'm just going to have a pink triangle
instead of the Illuminati Illuminati.
Look at that,
you know,
but he was bad.
Um,
my brother was really into thinking
Branson.
I love motorcycles.
I'm just scared of crashing.
Yeah,
well you can't,
well,
I mean you can't have him here,
but it's all dangerous.
Yeah.
I know.
If I live somewhere like real quiet,
oh sure man.
Sit or getting one,
like awesome.
And that's like,
yeah.
And growing up in central New York,
you could do that,
but not here.
Or my daughter wouldn't allow me to do
that.
She would,
she just made it really clear.
You know,
there's just so much fun,
but it's just,
it doesn't seem worth the risk.
Yeah.
It's bad here.
So that you,
so you had a maniac brother.
That's,
so that's a lot of people's perception
of hunters is a hunters are crazy people
that just like kimberly was just
outside.
I mean,
yeah,
there are a lot of people like that
though,
that are hunters.
Hunters want to deny,
but my brother also still had his
ethics,
like he ate what?
He killed this guy and he's sold at,
I mean,
he,
you know,
he was a trapper.
He,
he,
he just didn't like the man.
I get it.
It was one time where he was eluding the
warden and,
um,
uh,
it's just,
it's just all this stuff.
So they took off on a lake,
which wasn't thought,
oh no,
we lost the car.
Oh No.
They drove on a lake,
took acid,
and went fishing in the swan because
they had these big carpet in there.
So he's tripping balls,
which is like a public pond or
something.
Yeah.
It's like where you'd go.
Take your family.
So in the moon night out for the,
yeah,
I remember once,
uh,
oh,
what was that guy's name?
Big Mitch.
We W I went to an almond brothers
concert when I was like 12 and Mitch had
been the nom and he was tripping and he
was totally,
he was seeing Charlie in the parking lot
while he's driving the car.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
So that was my upbringing.
Wow.
So we got on this from hunters.
Um,
you know,
it's funny,
I'm,
I'm Vegan,
but I have more respect for people that
actually kill the animal,
which would eat eggs from my,
I'm not anymore.
I mean I did for a long time,
but I'm not like a opposed to other
people doing it.
And I actually,
I'm not trying to kiss your ass.
I have respect for people to kill it
because then they're not removed from
it.
You know what I mean?
There's this weird thing when you just,
you know that,
that's the weird part to me.
Well it's,
it's uh,
well it's dark because you don't know
where it came from.
So that's sort of,
it reduces your responsibility and you
don't really have to look into where the
man from.
And then that's where factory farming
comes from him because we're,
we're sort of ignorant to it.
And I grew up eating game venison where
there's seven people in the family.
So why wouldn't you eat eggs?
Cause you don't like the idea of
chickens and captivity or you don't want
them for health reasons.
I just stopped eating m and a it,
you know,
I had a heart attack a little bit a
while ago and,
and part of it's funny,
when I got off of that stuff,
everything,
my heart's in great shape,
which when I had the heart attack,
I knew I wasn't dying.
And I've truly,
it just recently done in May,
I was thinking about it.
The,
my,
my thoughts weren't like,
oh I'm going to die.
My thought was I'm going to have to lose
weight.
I was really angry.
I'm going to have to work out.
I was like furious over that idea.
That's fine.
I mean,
we talked about this,
that stage,
but it's true.
One of,
uh,
[inaudible] like after a few weeks of
walking,
an hour after dinner,
I was out.
I was like,
I don't care,
you know.
But,
but a cat was missing in the
neighborhood and that would motivate me
to walk.
Oh to look for the cat.
I was going to find it.
There's no missing cats.
Yeah,
I know was coyote.
But I found a cat that I thought was the
cat and then I carried it about maybe a
quarter of a mile back to the telephone.
Paul,
who's the wrong cat?
Yeah.
And I'm still a cat.
This is all to bring it back.
Yeah.
Cause yeah,
I love animals.
So I,
so I brought it to the house where I
thought it lived at and then I knocked
on this woman's door and I did.
And then she opened the door and the cat
ran and I swear to God and then the
woman goes,
she looks left and right and he goes,
Huh?
It goes in like,
oh,
I guess the cat's not going on the
doing.
And then I just didn't know you were
there.
No,
cause I didn't want to go,
hey,
I think I stole your cash.
Thought the fucking cat knocked on my
door.
I call bullshit.
Because they have furry little knuckles.
She wouldn't hear it.
Well when I let my cat out,
he will me out cause I don't let them
out for long periods of time.
But I'll let him out during the day.
If you want to wander around the yard
cause he'll just hang around in the
house.
But I worry about hawks hawks or,
yeah,
we have coyote and I'm in my back yard
and I live in silver lake.
Yeah.
Cartoons are everywhere.
They're all throughout the entire 50
states.
If there's,
if you're interested in the,
the history of the coyote,
there's an amazing podcast called the
mediator.
It's by this Guy Steve,
and he interviews
this Guy Dan Flores,
who's a historian,
wildlife historian.
He's a professor and he wrote a book
recently on coyotes.
Coyotes were originally,
um,
only western animals and they used to
call them prairie wolves.
That's what they used to call them.
They're actually a type of wolf.
It's a small wolf.
Wow.
And when people started hunting coyotes
kit and killing coyotes,
and then reintroducing gray wolves into
like yellowstone park and all sorts of
areas in Idaho and North America,
that's when the coyote spread across the
entire range of the continental United
States.
Now there's coyotes in every city in the
country.
Yeah.
There's coyotes in the adirondacks in
New York.
We'll have more babies.
This is what's crazy.
Like when you hear coyote screaming at
900,
what they're doing is like roll call
apparently according to this Dan Flores
God,
and they call out and when there's less
response,
like when one of them is missing,
it triggers a response in the female to
have larger litters.
Wow.
Significantly larger.
That crying is the equivalent of
Bueller.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
So they had apparently us a number of
coyotes that they had estimated in
yellowstone.
Then they brought in the gray wolves.
And the gray wolves are different than
red wolves and a couple other wolves
that are pretty much stet stayed and
steady,
uh,
population numbers in North America.
Well,
when the gray wolves came back in North
America,
they didn't treat coyotes like,
like friends.
They killed them.
And so when they started killing them as
opposed to interbreeding with them,
like you've heard of a Koi Wolf,
do you know what that is?
That's a big thing on the east coast,
which mostly red wolves and coyotes are
breeding.
They creating a larger,
smarter coyote and it's because the
coyote is really our wolves.
So when they started doing this,
they killed 50% of the coyote.
The coyote population dropped down to
50%.
But then because they have larger
litters,
when one of them gets killed,
now it's ramped up in 20 years higher
than it was before.
The reintroduction of the wolves.
Well,
um,
survivor matt and I have to say,
I mean they're,
they're creepy.
Uh,
when you see them,
the way they move,
they,
I've seen when I saw one scale,
a wall,
like just climb over and killed one of
my chickens,
I saw it run over a wall with my chicken
six foot wall and they climb.
It was nothing.
Yeah,
it's weird.
Like,
uh,
it's like human in the way it walks.
Superintelligent.
Yeah.
But I have to say I as scary as they are
and all that,
I,
there's a part of me that goes,
sorry man,
I know I'm in your yard.
You know what I mean?
I,
I realized that,
you know,
I'm the intruder,
really,
really?
No,
no,
no.
Don't feel that about coyotes.
No,
no.
Because look,
they go where the food is.
We go where the food is.
We're all sharing the space together.
It's not there.
It's not ours.
It's just weird now.
I mean,
you see this,
you say it's a wolf.
I see a wolf in my backyard,
but they hang around where people are
because that why?
Because we were way off.
Yeah.
We're the food as so where the road in
Sar because we have a lot of trash.
Yeah.
They're really important because they
kill off all the rats.
That's really important.
Yeah.
They kill the rats.
They kill rabbits.
They kill a lot of things that would get
out of hand,
uh,
population wise.
If it wasn't for them.
I,
uh,
yeah.
I don't let,
I don't let Anderson Cooper out or,
or Alice Cooper,
those are my cats.
Yeah.
Not during the day for sure.
I just,
I or not at night.
Excuse me.
Yeah.
I'm not going to let him out.
You just don't do it at all.
Nah,
Nah.
You know,
I,
I think that actually reminds me of it.
I don't know if I want to tell that
story.
I was going to tell him I have a woman
leftover,
a whip at my house.
Yeah.
Whip it.
Good.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and I have to say that like,
I wasn't like,
I don't think I'm a prude,
but,
and she's a very sweet person,
but she was like,
I know where she was going,
obviously.
Yeah.
And well,
she surprised me with it.
And so,
yeah,
I don't know was like that.
I don't know.
You know,
that's not my thing.
I don't have any crops,
but,
um,
no.
So here's the thing.
Like I,
I make this joke,
which drew,
I retired from acting the same time.
People stopped hiring me.
But no,
I really don't like to act.
I understand how you,
it's,
I don't like it.
I don't like it either.
And no one believes you when you say
that.
Yeah.
They think you're just think you're
lying and they think I'm lying.
I love directing.
I love writing.
I love being behind the scenes.
I love making stuff.
I like doing standup,
but I,
I think it's hard.
Back in the day when,
you know,
when I was in movies going,
I mean that wasn't acting,
you know,
if I forgot a line,
come on,
let's go.
You know,
so I don't know if that was acting,
but,
but she was like,
ah,
this.
So when she said,
she said,
I like to be dominated.
So that meant now,
um,
I have an acting part,
you know what I mean?
I like to be done and I'm like,
line,
I'm sorry,
I'm not a book.
You know,
and this sounds very almost borscht
belt,
but I did say that.
She goes,
she goes,
I've been a bad girl.
And I,
I said,
um,
well,
we're all flawed.
It's like a woody allen.
My,
yeah,
I did say that.
And then we laughed.
And I would just rather,
uh,
let's,
let's have sex.
Let's not,
I don't want to,
yeah,
I'm that way too.
I'm not in a choking anybody.
Well with you that would,
I just,
I just don't,
I mean it takes on a whole nother level.
Yes,
I bet.
I just put them,
I just,
I don't get the connection.
I mean I get where someone could get the
connection.
You know,
I was talking to a friend of mine,
my friend Chris Ryan who wrote this book
a sex at dawn,
he's a professor or a phd and he's a
really interesting guy.
And he was talking about where people
get fetishes from and then when you're
sort of imprinted at a young age,
as you're going through puberty,
sometimes very odd things will happen
and those things will happen.
You'll connect those things because they
happened with you sexually and they sort
of imprint in your system.
And he used it as a,
and as an example of how someone could
get their dick sucked by a guy when
they're like 13 or 14 and not even be
gay,
but really like getting your Dick sucked
by.
Guys like you get turned on by like guys
sucking guys dicks or something.
Like you can actually like imprint in
your mind,
but meanwhile you're attracted to women,
but you have this like weird kink for
this one thing.
It's very strange.
But give me an example of other ones.
I mean,
then,
yeah,
how's that way?
Why would you,
why would you get in the feet?
I don't know.
Like somebody rubbed their feet on you,
like right before you had sex.
Like some girl rubbed her feet on your
Dick and was into it,
you know,
and just playing around.
And I mean,
that does,
it can happen.
I mean,
I'm sure anything can happen.
Obviously there's things going on
between like a person like you or I who
doesn't want to hit anybody with a whip
and someone who's like really into it.
Yeah.
Also though,
I mean,
yeah,
there is something different to happen,
but it's not like I'm like,
oh,
that's disgusting and weird.
It just doesn't do anything for me.
It's not,
it just takes me out of the game.
Yeah.
Why don't I just,
I don't ever want to
associate sex and violence together.
I just don't think that's a good
combination.
In My,
my world,
I don't like it,
but I get it.
Like I have a buddy of mine who,
him and his girlfriend,
they put ball gags on each other and
beat the shit out of each other and they
love each other.
Yeah.
Great.
I mean,
they don't really,
they don't come away marked or anything
like that,
but there's some hair Poland and some
smacking around.
Well,
but,
but you're,
but you're a fighter,
you know what I mean?
So you know what I mean?
So it's to the,
it's like it's,
it's ruining something you love.
Yes.
Oh yeah.
I guess in that way.
Different things in your mind
sort of.
But the way I look at that,
I don't see like that's the kind of
violence was like,
someone's like,
hit me,
I want you to hit me.
Like that is not martial arts.
So like,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I know that's not remotely the same
thing.
Even if it's not even connected with
sex.
I don't want have anything to do with
that.
Like the idea of martial arts is someone
doesn't want to be hit.
You're trying to hit them and it becomes
this crazy game with extreme
consequences,
extreme health consequences.
There's nothing that's,
that's so different than holding someone
down with a rape joke and just smacking
him in the face over and over again
until they start crying while you're
fucking them.
Like people are into weird shit like
that and I,
my brain doesn't understand those
connections,
but some people do.
Like that guy,
the CBC radio host in Canada that had
all these girls saying that he just was
into beaten him up and he would say he
wants to have rough sex and they
thought,
you know,
hey,
it'd be a little hair.
Poland spank me when he's punching him
in the face and shit.
You know,
I allegedly,
I mean,
I dunno who's apparently he the trial,
right?
They dismissed the case and so now
they're going to retry him,
I guess under some other case or other
people.
There's,
I mean,
then yeah,
there was some lying apparently by the
girls and also they had 5,000 text
messages between the two of them going
back and forth about the details of the
case and what they should say and what
they shouldn't say.
So obviously there was some collusion.
Obviously there was some deception or
allegedly some deception,
but,
but what the fuck is it?
And this guy was like identified as a
male feminist.
He was like mister soft spook in.
Yeah,
but you're liberal.
But that's true.
That's actually a crown drop is this
really recently.
Okay,
so he signed a peace bond in the crown,
drops a sexual assault case.
What does that mean?
What does a peace bond?
Some Canadian shit.
What does a peace bond click on that
common and critical Cesa first
highlighted up at the top.
Yeah,
there you go.
What does a peace bond?
They're fairly common in criminal cases.
Defense lawyer says,
but that poor guy lost like 10 years of
his life through his whole thing.
Peace Bond isn't usual.
Is isn't unusual as a way to resolve a
criminal case as a lawyer.
In the wake of the news that former CBC
broadcast or John Gomez,
she is expected to sign one to conclude
his second sexual assault case.
A source who did not want to be
identified told CBC News of the case
will not go to trial in June as
previously scheduled.
Instead,
the charges is expect to be dealt with
on Wednesday.
The incident is alleged to have happened
in 2008 counselors.
Counselors,
cases are resolved via a peace bond.
I don't know what the fuck that means.
A resolution.
What does a peace plan?
It's still not saying.
Yeah.
I'm not sure.
He's an odd dude though,
because he was like,
Mister,
Mister liberal classic.
Yeah,
right.
Those clash.
Yeah.
I've,
I'm,
there's,
oh,
there's those guys,
those guys,
but you know how many of those guys have
rage issues?
Do you know what I mean?
That that,
that real,
there's so many of that.
Folks like these hippie folks and they
have this rage.
It's just really strange.
It's,
yeah,
it's not,
well also I find that a lot of guys who
identify as male feminists,
what happened for a lot of them is
they're there.
They had rough childhoods and they were
rejected by women.
So they become this like savior of women
from all these other asshole ish men.
Right.
And so they become the guy that's
different.
But they're womanizers.
Yeah,
it's not even that they're womanizers
what they are is they just a guy but
there a weak guy and they're suffering
from the trauma of like,
I have a friend,
it's not a friend anymore,
but I had a friend when I was younger
who had,
he was,
he wasn't an attractive guy and he would
have real issues with women,
not like him.
He would get so upset.
And he started,
over the course of the six or seven
years I knew him,
he started associating women with pain.
Like they would reject him and they
would be mean to him.
And he was going all the wrong places,
like going to like,
you know,
hotspots and getting bottle service and
and that was the type of people you're
attracting.
And so they just wanted to have his
drinks and not wanna have sex with him
and he would associate women with,
with pain and frustration and rejection.
And so he started becoming this angry
guy and I watched this sort of
metamorphosis and I,
and I,
and I was trying to analyze it like,
you know,
I was trying to do like the Louis Leakey
anthropology thing.
I'm trying to figure out what the fuck
is causing this stress and pain and
anger.
And it's just purely as association
game.
It's like how some people start looking
at Hollywood like Hollywood's all
bullshit,
man.
I'm tired as fuck.
Why?
Well because you keep going to the
auditions and they keep turning it down.
Right?
And so you just decide,
well fuck this place man.
It's places fake.
But meanwhile,
if you got scooped up when you're 20
years old,
yeah,
you would love this place.
It'd be the guy at the red carpet.
You would be like the toast of the town,
you'd be so happy.
And so I think a lot of these guys that
identify as male feminists,
I think they're just pussies.
And what happened is when they were
young,
they got walked over,
they got trampled,
and they're trying to figure out what is
the pattern of behavior that I have to
follow for me to separate myself from
these men that have ruined these girls'
lives.
I know I'll offer myself up as the
solution.
And as a feminist,
I just feel like it's just really been
fucked over.
Well.
But I mean,
there's a couple of things I run into
the other guys who,
uh,
crimmins has it term,
feminized,
who are,
who are acting,
I'll sensitive but still pulling mad.
Well,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
He's like,
I understand it.
The same guy,
the same guy.
Different Hustle.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
Feminizing and uh,
uh,
but you know,
I mean,
at the end of the day,
feminist,
it's,
you know,
basic human rights.
I'm all for that.
Of course.
I just,
the problem is that the definition and
the [inaudible] and those guys who,
uh,
I questioned there.
Integrity.
Yes.
Well,
men are very difficult in that regard.
It's very difficult while they're
sexually viable because they,
they're looking for attention,
they're trying to score and when they're
trying to score,
they try any sort of combination of
words.
Right.
It might be possible.
Like I met this one guy said he's a
feminist and then he told me he's
polyamorous.
I go,
Oh,
you're a pussy hat.
And I see how,
I just know,
I just don't want to control my woman.
I don't want to read.
I respect her pleasure,
her right to seek pleasure fucker.
You fucker.
I see you.
I respect her,
man.
I uh,
yeah,
I think,
um,
yeah,
I mean,
I don't know when the,
when the,
there's what,
when did men start becoming feminists?
Was it Alan Alda?
Did he pulled that shit first?
Uh,
no.
I think it's,
but you know,
the seventies,
sixties,
you just started saying it.
I mean,
I'm sure like Warren Beatty was,
even though I guarantee he was such a
pussy.
I know,
I know.
I guarantee he was.
Hmm.
Maybe.
I think you know,
people don't like the term egalitarian.
They think it's a cop out like,
oh no,
no,
no.
If you really cared about women's
rights,
you'd identify yourself as a feminist.
Like,
no,
I'm,
I like humans.
Like all of them I like,
I like nice women.
I like Nice Ben.
I liked pink Barbie.
Obviously major things,
you know the,
the,
the pay gap is,
is a,
is a real good,
it's tricky.
You're looking at that.
A lot of political bullshit,
the actual reality pay gap.
It's very minor.
There's only a few jobs where women
actually do get paid less than men.
What the pay gap is,
is overall judging how much money women
make versus how much money men make and
not taking into account what jobs they
do.
What,
what,
what jobs men tend to gravitate towards
naturally versus what jobs women tend to
gravitate towards naturally.
But when they're in the same job with
the same sort of production there,
their actual payscale is very similar.
It's real tricky man because you can't
deny that some people that are a certain
gender,
like they gravitate towards certain
occupations and those occupations might
have higher risk,
they might have a higher pay ceilings.
There's,
there's a lot of variables and then you
have to take into account women taking
time off for raising children,
for being pregnant,
all those things,
having babies,
maternity leave.
That all gets factored in when you're
talking about how much time or how much
money people actually make.
So if you say women should be paid
maternity leave and they should get x
amount of money from a corporation,
then you're dealing with a totally
different argument.
And if you do that then the pay scale
changes,
then it goes up a little bit.
And if you say,
well everybody should get paid for the
same exact same exact money for the same
job.
Even still more men want to do certain
jobs in engineering and science.
And then when it comes to like really
dangerous jobs,
you know,
men are much more likely to die on the
job.
Men are much more likely to be murdered
by other men.
There's like a lot of weird shit that
get has to get factored in when you talk
about a payscales and apparently it's
one of those political things where
people say it and then I it.
And then someone corrected me on it and
then I said,
but I heard Obama say it because Obama
was talking about the glass ceiling and
how much money and the disparity in
income.
And then I started actually looking into
it,
I went,
oh,
okay,
this is complicated because it's one of
those things where you don't want to be
insensitive.
So you don't want to say that's
bullshit.
Women don't get paid any less than men
do.
But when you actually do look at the
real numbers,
that's where they're getting it from.
It's not like there's a hundred lawyers.
Okay.
Let's use an example about,
uh,
in,
in Showbiz.
Cause,
uh,
you,
there is a,
a big difference an actresses and actors
pays.
Are there your top actors?
Well,
the people that can sell the most
tickets,
you get the most money.
Like Jennifer Lawrence gets paid shit,
piles of money.
And there was that thing where she was
saying that she was upset that she
didn't get as which one is Bradley
Cooper,
but Bradley Cooper was in way more
scenes than her.
He was in way more of the movie and he
was a bigger star at the time.
Like it's,
it's real tricky because of Jennifer
Lawrence was in a movie with you.
She get paid way more than you.
Well,
let's be,
you know what I'm saying?
Or I probably would pull more money,
but,
but you know what I'm saying,
right.
It's like if someone is a huge
superstar,
um,
uh,
what's her name from friends?
Jennifer Aniston.
Jennifer Aniston in her prime,
you know,
or,
um,
the Matt and Mike and Molly Guy.
What's the girl's name?
Miss Melissa.
Melissa McCarthy.
Yeah.
You don't think she makes more than him?
Of course she does.
She's more popular.
She's more famous.
She does these giant movies.
She gets paid tons of money.
Amy Schumer gets paid tons of money.
And I'm going to just change the
subject,
uh,
cause I was thinking of back to your
bears and movies.
What was your take on revenue?
I liked it.
You know,
it's all based on an actual true story
that uh,
this Guy Steve Rinella from that
mediator podcast who actually a
historian himself in a way,
he told me the story,
the actual story where,
um,
they really did leave this guy for dead
and he really did crawl for a couple of
miles and figured out a way to survive
and got to that guy and killed them.
It's a real true story.
Um,
I thought it was pretty good,
man.
It's three.
It's really interesting.
I mean,
someone who's actually been relatively
close to a wild bear,
what did you make of the scenes?
People do see it looked really
realistic.
People do occasionally survive bear
attacks like that.
Cause a lot of times the bears are just
trying to protect themselves or they're
trying to protect her because you fuck
up.
You get to close their cubs that that's
a lot of it.
Yeah.
That's the thing,
uh,
about bears is that you may not know
that you're between the cub.
Yeah.
You might not have any idea.
You gotta be super careful and if you're
worried about you,
I know what I'm doing.
I mean,
there's,
there's a certain amount of risk.
There's a certain amount of risk.
Last one is no,
watch me.
I know what I'm doing.
I don't,
let me try this.
I don't go where grizzlies are.
Stay with the black bears are like,
if I do see a grizzly,
we're fucking out of there pretty
quickly.
You gotta you gotta be careful,
but there's a certain amount of risk to
it.
Did you see grizzly man?
Yeah.
Many times.
I always want to for the bears.
Yeah.
Okay,
great.
Yeah,
I was the same thing as I go there.
That's an interesting case because that
guy is obviously mentally allianced
willow creek,
probably more than any other movie
really will,
if people haven't seen it.
It's Bob's bigfoot movie,
which we're going to get back to big
foot.
Well,
when Willow Creek came out,
I was in the middle of my big flip
phase.
Yeah,
it was,
it was just ending.
And what killed it for me was when I did
that Scifi show with Duncan trussell and
we went to the Pacific northwest and
hung out with a few big foot hunters for
a week.
And after a while we're like,
dude,
we realized it was,
I had a joke about it.
I said,
here's what you don't find.
When you go looking for bigfoot black
people,
you're more likely to find big foot.
Then you are black people looking for
bigfoot.
What you find is hordes of unfuckable
white dudes out camping.
And I'm like,
this is an undeniable statistic.
I'm not going to lie.
That was something I noticed this
weekend at the Ohio big foot conference.
Honest to God,
I was like,
it was,
you know,
it was huge.
And I,
at one point I said,
where the brothers that they don't
exist.
There was two guys,
there was two black guys.
Yeah.
They were,
um,
they were lost.
They were looking for.
They are looking for a car show.
It's this thing that men do get that
though.
I mean,
I truly was because I shot some stuff,
Megan to document.
I said,
hey man,
we need some people of color,
which I was told they don't exist.
You have to cast him.
Did you try,
did you try women?
Did you get any women?
They all like the same kind of like
count.
What am I,
what am I favorite makeup?
One of my favorite interviews was a gal
who was 16 years old and she was quite
brilliant.
I really loved her.
She was,
yeah,
she,
she was my,
one of my favorite interviews,
talk to Les Stroud.
You should talk to less who I wasn't,
I'm not doing it like a definitive big
foot.
I want him to do out of short about this
festival,
you know,
there's conference and uh,
that was the idea.
Uh,
and uh,
so yeah,
Bob Gimlin was there.
Your,
your,
your buddy.
Did He,
did you ask him about the story and of
course what it,
what does he say?
He tells the story,
you know,
he tells it like it actually happened.
Yeah.
One of the things interesting about him
is that he talks about the amount of
time he actually got to see big foot
versus a Roger Paris and who are
scrambling around with the camera.
And what'd he say?
Oh,
he was just talking about,
he,
he felt that he didn't film a lot,
you know,
and he didn't,
I mean it's only 942 of the frame.
Yeah.
Or he did because he helped the guy get
the fucking suit on.
So obviously to,
you know,
do you know,
did we talk about the um,
uh,
[inaudible] no,
no,
we duck up.
We've talked about that.
But did you the John Landis,
John Landis though the film director.
What about them?
Well,
um,
I'm really sorry.
I was up since 4:00 AM,
who was the guy in,
uh,
Argo.
That was it.
Yeah.
That was the movie where John Goodman is
playing the makeup effects guy.
I don't believe I saw that movie.
Right.
So,
so that's a real guy.
And uh,
he worked too.
I believe we worked with land is yeah,
John Chambers and he'd worked with land
is and
um,
so there was a rumor that John Land is,
is in the patty suit in the actual big
foot suit itself.
Oh,
I never heard.
So I wanted,
I wrote to John Landis,
I asked that's not go well.
I say to my agents because they are how
he's looking for me to try to do
something that makes money.
So I go,
Hey,
I got this idea for a TV show.
I want to talk to John Landis about,
I don't know what John Landis,
I don't have an idea for a TV joke.
Can you get me his email?
So they get me John Landis and email and
I write him and spoke play.
I'm writing an article for magazine and
I was wondering if you'd like to talk to
me about this rumor about you possibly
being in the Patterson Gimlin footage.
Uh,
you know,
in a,
in a suit playing patty five minutes,
I can get an answer back.
He gets,
how did you get my email?
That's how it starts.
Who are you writing an article for her
and most certainly not in a big foot
suit at the past.
So I went back and forth and kind of
calmed him down a bit.
But yeah,
it's such a bad suit too.
It's not a bad suit.
You,
you see,
he keeps saying it's terrible.
What is it about that footage?
It's obviously a man.
It's,
you know why it's obviously a man.
Why?
Because it looks like a man in a suit.
There's no other animal that looks like
a man in a suit.
You don't look at a giraffe and go,
that looks like a fucking dude in a
giraffe suit.
But you look at that big foot and you
go,
that looks like a fucking man.
It's walking like a man.
It has the same sort of stride.
It just has longer arms because he's got
football helmet,
shoulder pads or football shoulder pads
on and his arms.
He's got these long fucking fake ass
arms.
So like the whole line is fake and
breath.
Why not?
How do you know?
First of all it says,
Oh,
here we go again.
We've done this a lot.
Yeah.
There it goes.
Now what do you see breasts?
What?
I see a shitty suit.
No back.
There's,
but what animal has Harry tits?
Do you know?
Even gorillas,
even gorillas are unexposed.
Yeah,
it's fucking,
it's shitty.
It's pointing it over.
It's got shoulder pads on.
I mean it looks like,
let me watch it again,
Bob.
You know shoulder pads go down like
this,
right?
They go down like that.
You might find this.
I know nothing about the sports.
I probably know as little about
football.
I don't even know the rules.
Go into the going to a,
all right,
here we go.
Why?
But here's my point.
Why would you give it,
why would you give it breasts?
Cause it's a shitty suit.
Look,
look at the bottom of his feet.
It's so obviously shoes.
Like it's fake ass.
The whole thing is stupid.
[inaudible] here,
looking at this footage going now let's
stable.
All right.
See now you're about to eat some crow.
Boy,
let me tell you something.
One time I got so high I was watching
this documentary.
I was watching this footage.
I was like,
what if I'm an asshole?
And that really is big foot.
Okay.
What do you mean?
Like you hurt big foot's feelings.
I'm just been mocking this for so long.
Why do you hate the bears and Gameland
footage?
Because the first of all,
look at how little it's legs are a
little skinny ass fucking stupid legs
that is not carrying an enormous animal
around the woods for the is is how angry
you are at.
Cause I hate hoaxes and atomically first
of all right,
let's,
let's talk again.
Roger Patterson,
the guy wrote,
this is a con man.
[inaudible] man who was the guy who was
shot.
It went to jail for writing a bad check
to pay for the very camera.
They used to film big foot.
I mean he was a known con man.
Bob Hieronymus should get the video of
Bob Heran.
No blocking around him.
His footage,
you never see his feet.
So what do you mean watch?
His feet are crapped out so it doesn't
give you the same height as patty,
but it doesn't have to.
Thing isn't big there that people have
estimated that thing to be about six
foot three.
It's not that big.
That's a person.
All right.
You really think it's real?
Yeah.
I think it's real.
Oh,
you're so crazy.
Look at this.
Look.
First of all,
why he doesn't have legs?
He's walking.
I Dunno because it's the same height as
him.
I Dunno.
I don't know why I want an answer.
Maybe make another one.
Holy Spirit will come on.
Look at that.
That is hilarious.
That's the guy.
Could you mean it literally is him.
Cause you shoulder pads on that guy.
He's always swinging his arms.
Could you put Yakety Sax?
I knew this.
That guy's a big goofy northern
California,
Oregon type character.
You put Yakima Shit,
Bill.
But you think it's real?
Yeah.
So you think it's a real big foot?
Do you think big foot's real?
Like right now it's still alive?
Uh,
yeah.
Really?
Yeah.
For Real?
What makes you think this?
Well,
I,
uh,
oh,
can I prove it?
No,
no,
I'm not saying what do I believe?
What makes you say
the amount of people that I've talked to
that I,
that I'm looking at him and I,
and there's no reason for them to be
lying.
And the,
it's basically the stories that I hear
over and over where the sincerity I
don't get if it's not,
I don't understand what the,
the,
uh,
you know,
what is this mass thing that I'm,
um,
of,
you know,
um,
I've had guys after the movie,
like,
you don't have like people that come up
to me and they're almost like,
yeah,
it's,
I mean,
maybe they're trying to get a connection
with me,
but I also feel like they're relieved to
tell someone this.
Now,
did they see big foot?
No.
Maybe it's their imagination and stuff.
Maybe a lot of these stories,
but just the amount of the stories is
fascinating to me.
It is.
Well,
one of the things they've realized
fairly recently is that black bears in
particular tend to walk on their hind
legs a lot.
Yeah.
A lot more than anybody ever thought.
Not only that they and they'll knock a
tree down towards you.
Yeah.
And they can walk on there.
They can walk on their hind legs for
great distances and they,
they're incredibly strong and especially
the big ones.
Like,
um,
a friend of mine shot one the other day
on a hunt in Alaska that was seven foot,
almost eight foot long.
Look,
I'm going to show you a picture of him
holding this fucking thing up and you
think about this animal standing up on
its hind legs and what,
what it would look like if that thing
was walking towards you.
Now my friend John is six foot five and
that guy,
now that's clearly someone in a suit.
No,
no,
no.
That's a bear bro.
No,
no,
no.
I,
I agree.
I totally see how enormous that is.
No,
and I agree that the majority of of
people who see big foot and eight foot
long black bear,
but that does stand,
that just walks around as a lot of the
behavior that people attribute it to.
Big Food.
I think that's what they're seeing.
And also I think you're also dealing
with woods.
The Pacific northwest with a sightings
are primarily occurring,
is insanely dense.
The way I described it when we went up
to I,
I've been on rain here,
it's like cue tips.
Yeah.
Like you know,
like a box of cute tips.
It's the same.
The trees look like you can't see 2030
yards in,
it's gone.
It's like,
no,
you can't just treat anything.
Yeah.
And so the canopy keeps light from
coming in.
So if you saw,
first of all,
the fear that would go through your
mind.
If you saw a seven foot black bear
walking on a time,
legs through the woods and you saw it in
between trees,
your mind would fill in the blanks and
big foot has become this architectural,
archetypical cultural cultural icon.
But that is something that I,
not only big foot,
but almost all archetypal characters.
Uh,
I,
and the devil and all these things.
I am fascinated with this as a,
as someone who does write screenplays
and tell stories,
I always wonder,
well,
what,
what in the subconscious are they
supplying?
Is it just something is from,
from,
from our ancestors that,
you know what I mean?
Then some or,
or does it supply,
this is how you told your kids not to go
in the woods.
You know,
I am fascinated by what these different
archetypal characters are and why
they're created,
if they are created and things like
that.
Um,
I think there was an animal at one time.
It's not that,
Everyone knows it's a hundred percent
fact.
There was animal called gigantic pithy.
Yes.
We all know this.
Right?
It was a huge,
it's ingrained in us that,
that our fear of that,
I think that thing lived alongside
people for a long time.
And I think when you talk about like
native American,
right?
They,
when they're their folklore or when they
talking about big foot and they have,
apparently they have many,
many words for sasquatch.
Yeah.
Um,
and I think that
what they're probably doing is passing
on thousands of years of data.
We don't know when the last time
gigantic epiphysis was alive because
they didn't know Jack [inaudible].
This was even an animal until the 1920s,
I believe it was.
They went to an apothecary shop and
China and,
uh,
an anthropologist found a tooth that he
couldn't attribute to any other known
primate.
He asked the people where they got it
from.
They told them where they got it from.
They went to the actual area where they
got these bones and they found jawbones
that would indicate the animals by
pedal.
And that's where things get really
interesting because you're dealing with
some bipedal enormous animal that was
most likely a at least eight feet tall.
Right.
So a huge eight foot tall primate.
I mean,
we know the gorillas are huge and we
know that,
you know,
there's the Bondo eight which has this
enormous chimpanzee that has just
recently been confirmed to live in the
Congo.
They have a chimpanzee and the Congo
that's like six feet tall,
400 pounds,
so enormous champ.
So there are like variables,
there's V,
there's different kinds of primates.
They know about the hobbit man and
Flores that lived as recently as,
I want to say,
14,000 years ago,
that,
that thing that lived on the
[inaudible],
that's fascinating little tiny people
that they think also cannibalized humans
and they think that human beings might
have driven them to extinction.
They use tools.
They were like an enemy,
little tiny person thing that killed
people perhaps.
So I think a lot of our,
our thoughts about like leprechauns and
it sounds like a really good healthy,
it does.
It's also people that believe that
animals still exists or that,
that,
that small creature,
the Orang deck is a one I think is in
Vietnam.
They believe that this,
uh,
this animal's still exists and people
still have sightings of this.
And I think that that little little guy
is probably more likely still alive and
then the gigantic.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
uh,
I think it's,
it's,
uh,
for me it's,
it's,
I'm not copping out.
I mean,
I do believe,
but I also love the whole whole idea of
it.
And you've been in the woods and you
know you can't see three feet in front
of you.
And I love it when I'm out with folks
and theirs,
they'll hear an owl that sounds like a,
it sounds like an ape screaming.
And then the man that's as know and they
know.
Then I hear something else and they go,
I got,
hey man,
that sounds like a coyote.
He's like,
well,
you know a juvie squat sometime
impersonate other animals,
juveniles,
June squatch,
Juvi squatch,
the Frank Kelly Andro of a dose of the
sasquatch was a bit from my last special
that I did.
That was a real conversation I had with
one of these big foot hunters.
And he goes,
one time I was walking in the woods and
I heard this bull frog that was near a
blackberry Bush,
and I was thinking to myself,
why is a bull frog near a blackberry
Bush?
And then I got home and I realized that
was a squatch and he was dead serious,
maybe was just a fucking frog.
Maybe it was just a frog in his mind.
It had to be a sasquatch,
like that kind of,
you got to that part of the story that
quick because when you ask,
oh,
it took a long time.
[inaudible] you go,
have you had any encounters?
And that goes,
I'm five foot six and I'm like,
now the date was 1972 and I would like
it had a brand new pair of shoes and I
had just broken one lace and what tobby
other lace up.
And I was thinking to myself,
I'm so upset with the way they're making
these lasers these days.
They've shipped off the relationship.
Charles,
that's neither here nor there.
Anyway,
I'm on a long backpacking trip.
You ever watch the bionic man?
Oh with big?
No big foot was not in that.
It's just like,
it's never point a to b.
There's socially retarded.
They're adorable.
They are adorable and a lot of ways.
Look,
the guys that took me in and Dunkin,
the guys we will not with from the,
what is it?
The sasquatch research found one on the
fucking name.
Their organization has bfr fro.
Yes,
that's it.
Yeah.
They're nice guys.
But,
but I,
and I also love it because it's a,
to me it's a microcosm of faith.
You know,
there's the people that see it and
believe there's people that have never
seen it.
And then just like any other belief in a
deity,
uh,
everybody's got their own version and
everybody thinks their versions right.
And I love that.
That is all this in fighting.
You know,
like while I was there,
I would start asking people about,
well,
what do you think about dog man?
And people are like,
ah,
Ooh,
this guy's crazy.
Hey,
why don't you go back to holly weird
with that dog.
Man,
that's so funny,
man.
I can't think of a more fun weekend.
Um,
they think that he can sense where
cameras are.
Well,
different folks.
Yeah.
And there's,
those are the same folks who believe
he's travelling and portals to travel
some worm holes.
Yeah.
SASQUATCH is interdimensional creature.
I've met many people that can sense when
a camera's on.
But here's the thing,
here's the thing that I ask you.
What evidence at all,
if any,
compels you to think it's even possible
that this animal exists besides that
footprint that I have over there.
Do you see one of those?
I got one of those.
Is that the chromecast?
That's from one of the fucking
encounters.
I think that looks like,
um,
I hate to bum you out.
I think that it looks like from the
Patterson Gimlin track wave.
Yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
I think this is given to me by Bobo
from finding big foot.
Sure.
[inaudible] we got that.
How are you in Bobo get along?
Oh Great.
Cause we use it.
He was upset when I was ragging on that
fucking Bobo.
Uh,
uh,
when he found out I was doing a movie,
it's the first thing he said was,
um,
I'm going to fucking kick bobcat s he
says,
cause he thought I was going to make fun
of them.
Imagine that.
Make Fun of big foot and he wants to
kick your ass.
And you know,
I'm,
my movie is very reverential.
I'm not,
you know.
Thanks man.
I really enjoyed that movie.
And I remember calling you up right
after events.
Films,
a fun movie.
Thanks.
It's really good.
And He,
and shocking because I didn't know what
to expect.
Yeah.
Remember we barely talked about it.
He just told me it's a big foot movie.
I'm like,
all right.
And I watched this morning,
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
This scene and the tense is,
is,
is pretty happy with that.
And you know,
when we shot that scene it was 3:00 AM
2:33 AM and I shot it at at uh,
allows camp between last camp and Bluff
Creek.
So I shot it where the footage was
filmed.
Well and we'd seen a mountain lion.
Okay.
I can check to a guy who's seen a
mountain lion.
Yeah.
That's fucked up,
right?
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Have you seen with Oh yeah,
she too.
Yeah.
I saw one run across the road and that
was weird.
And then we saw one in the woods and
man,
it's,
it's crazy.
And it would have killed us,
but it didn't want it to because we
will,
any of you,
we were just really close to just got up
and just like walked away like a house.
Well,
they don't worry about people because
they haven't been hunted in California
since the 90s.
So all these animals that you're
experiencing,
they don't view people as nearly as much
of a threat as they used to.
But if you're like an Arizona or places
that have a hunting season,
you're not gonna see any fucking
mountain lions.
They see people,
they get the fuck out of there cause
they get there,
they understand the threat,
and they get used to the threat.
And then they escape and they run away.
Like,
here's a perfect example.
Uh,
yellowstone people haven't hunted in
yellowstone and over a hundred years.
So when you go to yellowstone,
you could pull your car up to a herd of
elk and they're right there hanging out,
right?
You can get out of your car and you
could see them.
When you're in Colorado,
you're in the mountains and you're
hunting and you see an elk.
They bark and they fucking bolt.
They see you.
They go like,
they let all the other elk knows,
they recognize the threat and they take
off.
Wow.
So,
because we don't hunt in California,
we don't hunt mountain lions.
Why you never see any deer.
That was really terrifying.
Uh,
and we filmed the scene to just film
the,
the Mount Mine.
No,
we've,
but we film there cause they go,
where did I go?
Well let's just go to the left.
And they go and Bryce Johnson's in the
film,
he's like,
why don't we just get in the car?
And so he was scared of the mountain and
we said,
well,
yeah,
I mean it was,
it was really big.
That's the thing I didn't realize it's a
lion.
Oh yeah.
You know,
it's big.
And then we're filming the scene that,
you know,
the long scene in the tent and the first
take,
it's 19 minutes long.
The one that's in the movie,
the first take,
he started crying while we were filming.
Why?
Because he's scared of them.
Outline a was just,
yeah,
it was the whole thing.
And you know,
and then you know,
that nature,
that scene is,
is and a,
I go,
that was really good take,
I just don't think your character would
cry.
And he's like,
my character is not crying.
I'm crying.
Why are we here?
We could shoot this in a hotel parking
lot.
No one knows where the fuck I go.
That's really good.
Use that intensity in the indices.
Just don't cry.
We're going again.
Aye.
Crimmons at the same
thing with me.
He,
he,
he laughed really hard.
Like I think I live a fairly honest
life,
but when I'm in production mode it's
just I'm going to get it done.
I have to truly though,
and its constraints.
And when we were filming,
call me lucky the doc,
I'm Barry,
um,
uh,
we were uh,
out on the lake and the ice started
cracking and uh,
one of the guys was from ice truckers,
so he knew the noise.
He goes,
hey,
we got to get off the ice.
Cause it was like boom,
boom.
Sounded like someone tuning and drum
pill.
Fine.
It was like,
have you ever,
it was like boom,
no.
And I go,
what do we do?
He goes,
everybody walk off the ice one at a
time,
15 feet,
20 feet between each other.
You know,
like we made a line but we were far away
from each other and it went from fat
guys and then,
and it actually did like a split,
like,
and then like snow blew up,
you know,
through this Kravis cars.
So we get off the ice and uh,
and there's this jetty and uh,
and I go,
okay guys,
I go,
this just,
just climb over the fence cause it says,
you know,
do not enter closed chain.
And I go,
just come up here and we just go down to
the end of the jetty and the sound guys
never worked with before.
He goes,
but the sign it says do not enter.
I go,
yeah,
the guy said if he wasn't here,
just jumped the fence.
It just jumps and Crimmons goes,
have you been lying to me this whole
time?
How you lie so fast?
Can I get the chart?
Windy
city.
He too.
Oh,
that's awful.
Oh that's how ridiculous we should pick
this.
I found out barry's doing a special,
uh,
and at the,
where is it land?
Uh,
Lawrence,
Kansas on June 4th.
Uh,
Louis Ck is producing a special for
bearing.
Yeah.
You Go,
oh,
that's so great at the Lawrence Art
Center.
Go out and check out their doing two
shows,
10 bucks tickets.
So beautiful.
And See Barry,
what is he filming it for?
I'm not sure.
I,
maybe it's for Louie.
You know how he has,
he puts stuff out.
I don't know.
I mean it could,
you know,
I don't know.
I should ask barry where it's just going
gonna be released on Louis C K.
Dot com.
Beautiful percent.
Sure.
But so it was beautiful.
Yeah.
Barry.
So awesome.
And I'm working on a lot of things.
I really am actually right now I'm
working on um,
a couple different things I'm not going
to discuss,
but one of the things I can discuss is
I'm doing a,
uh,
a short doc on the Washington generals.
The,
the team that played the gloved writers,
I don't know about that.
Oh,
they're the team that lost three and a
half thousand.
He was roughly,
because they played the globe drought
constantly in the fake games.
Again,
you're still wrestling,
right?
Well,
here's what I'm learning is really fun.
They like,
officially,
they were never told to take a dive,
but they knew it.
Yeah.
And then they fucked up once in 71,
and they'd be like,
oh my God.
And that's what I'm doing.
Oh,
children were crying in the stands at
meadowlark lemon went into the,
went into their,
uh,
into their locker and he goes,
you didn't win in the guy was great.
He goes,
but we knew we did.
So when the generals one when like other
people would win the NBA finals,
I'd be like,
well,
wait a minute.
Did they beat the globe?
Trotters were where the globe trotters
understand the globetrotters.
The Best I've seen in the bone.
Their fingers,
they do crazy stuff,
you know,
is just the actual game.
No,
no.
Uh,
but yeah,
man,
the glow chatter,
it's a little weird idea to like
incorporate theatrically and sort of
like,
almost like a sheryl wrestling type
thing with,
do they still do it?
Yeah.
Well there's the,
the simpsons with Krusty,
the clown,
he,
where he lost all his money betting on
the generals.
He goes,
I thought they would do,
I thought they were do rep luck.
He's pulling his pants down.
He's just spinning the ball,
grab it,
grab the ball.
I did the simpsons ride the other day.
Universal.
I took my kids a universal,
this simpsons ride is fucking amazing.
I loved it.
And there's so many jokes crammed into
that then too.
Yeah.
It's really funny.
Everything,
even when you're waiting to get on the
ride,
the screen,
they play you.
It's really well done.
One of the best rides of all times.
Yeah.
And a lot of laughs.
Oh,
did you catch this?
It replaced the back to the future ride.
It did.
Yeah.
And then they do a thing where,
uh,
where uh,
there's like a shady dealing between
crusty and doc brown and that's how the,
that's like he,
yeah.
So even that was really well done.
It's the same building and they just
retooled the ride basically.
Oh,
that's interesting.
So much better.
Yeah,
it's great.
It's really,
it's really like one of the best rides.
Lg Kid.
Well,
this was the young,
well I went with my one,
my seven who just turned eight and I
have a five is,
so you went with the eight year old.
Did you want to hear what all of them?
Yeah.
Well the eight year old went to Harry
Potter of the five year.
Couldn't get to Harry Potter.
Yeah,
she's two.
She's like an inch shot.
Next time on a stuffer shoes.
I'm going to get him to wear heels.
Yeah,
she was a little bumpy,
but the eight year old reads Harry
Potter,
like every day she's read three of the
books.
She reads chapters and chapters,
everything.
She's obsessed,
like she can't stop talking about Harry
Potter.
Did you get her a wand?
Oh yeah,
the whole deal.
We went through the whole rigamarole,
but the Harry Potter ride at universal
is probably the greatest ride in the
history of rides.
It's fucking amazing.
And I don't even like did you,
did you bring up a voldemort to any of
the employees?
Why?
What happens?
Because you're not supposed to make,
you mentioned them well,
their commitment is really impressive.
They go,
please do not say that you had,
what's the date?
What is it?
He has no go on.
Yeah.
He who cannot be named.
Please do not bring up here.
You cannot,
it's like that old graph a little bit
like I admire your commitment.
Uh,
but uh,
I know you came here from Encino,
right?
I just want to see if he's got a want.
Well,
and also they serve this stuff called
butter beer.
That I guess was a big thing.
And it's this unbelievably sugary like
Syrah be drink with like foam on the top
of it.
It's,
Oh,
it's disgusting.
And just everybody's drinking it
everywhere.
They're all really,
it's really well done.
Oh Man.
Amazing.
We all done the way it costs more than a
billion dollars.
One point $8 billion for Harry Potter
world.
Wow.
Yeah.
What in the fuck.
So that's that canoe rides a star wars
world.
Yeah.
That's even more Disneyland's Star Wars
right now.
Even more pricey.
And Aaron Spelling's Disney bought star
wars and so universal is Harry Potter.
I guess they were doing another world
too,
is I don't,
I'll look up,
but they're doing two or three giant
world spaces.
Like they got some lame mine rods.
Jurassic parks.
Land was fuck the,
the um,
transformers is lame as fuck.
They're too dated.
I didn't do it.
Those are lame.
Don't,
don't,
did you go through the King Kong in
these,
you didn't do that.
So that's pretty good.
The training.
Yeah.
Cause it's the tram goes in and it's,
it's three 60.
Uh Oh yeah.
Oh,
I did that a long time ago.
This is a long time ago,
right?
Isn't it like 10 or 20 years old or
something like that?
Yeah.
The backlog tour.
I did that back in the day.
I did that.
But,
uh,
I'm super impressed with the simpsons.
And even though that was like an
animatronic one that has banana breath.
No,
no,
this is Peter Jackson.
Three d 360 degrees screen.
Oh no,
it's a universal too.
Yeah,
it's nuts.
You got,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's,
that's really good.
No,
not that I remember that one.
Yeah.
And it had banana bread.
Who did it?
Yeah,
that's right.
It blows banana smell on you.
You blow bananas because it's come full
circle.
Let me get back to this big,
big foot conflicts.
What makes you think that any of this
like this stupid fake footprint in front
of us here?
What makes you,
I'll tell you,
you know,
it's hard to do this.
I'm not saying it's impossible.
They can see that American Werewolf in
London than I have out there.
Yeah.
If it's,
if that they could do that.
What would make you think they couldn't
do this?
Uh,
thermo ridges.
No,
no,
it's the,
I'll tell you what's hard.
Uh,
am I saying it's not impossible because
there was people being pulled behind a
truck,
you know,
so the,
the,
with a rope,
so the spacing and the feet and then
you've got enough force because you do
have to put a lot of pressure and to
make this.
But here's the weird part.
Um,
and this isn't,
this is improved,
but at what I was really a surprise
with,
cause we made footprints in,
in,
in Willow Creek and did it the way you
would think,
you know,
carved would put them on your feet
really hard to take that,
that second stride.
It's really strange.
It's like anti a snow shoes to the point
where I got stuck.
Maybe it's because I'm a fat ass,
but we had to get like a stick to get me
it.
It's not saying it's not impossible,
but it was really way Dif.
More difficult than I could imagine.
So fairly difficult.
But still that's the best piece of
evidence is just impressions and dirt.
Just tracks.
There's never been a body,
there's never been a trail cam
photograph of them.
Mean Hunter's set up trail camp photos
everywhere now that people have phones
on with cameras on them.
There's people hiking and hunting and
everyone has cameras and but yet folks
who have footage,
what footage is any good?
Wow.
Other than that fake footage that we
watched or what footage is any good
look,
a lot of people don't know that.
Roger Patterson also was Abraham
Zapruder cause it's the same camera
where he had one.
He had one thing he did really well.
That gigli camera.
Yeah.
Well when they leveled it out,
um,
it's just,
it's not compelling at all to me.
I really think it's fake.
Yeah.
Um,
but I wish it wasn't greeted,
disagree,
but I wish it wasn't a really do like,
I want it to be real.
It's one of my all time favorite myths.
So you would be thrilled if absolve.
Thrilled.
But that'd be so happy.
I probably sleep for days.
What would you do about,
um,
well that,
that's the thing,
that's weird too.
I wonder what people are seeing if
they're not seeing bigfoot because I
think they're seeing bears.
Yeah.
I think they're seeing bipedal bears
and,
or bullshit or the crazy or they're
making things up.
I think a lot of these people are lonely
and I think it's a,
it's an archetypal story.
It's just fascinated too though about
like when I went to the mosque men,
uh,
thing,
what,
what is it?
If it isn't this,
you know,
so why,
why is it,
is it the,
when you're getting ridiculed for coming
with a story,
why is it like over a hundred actual
reports,
police reports and stuff?
When I on this phenomenon where people
are seeing the month,
man,
you know what I'm saying?
So let's say it's fake or board,
but they're in Kentucky,
Meth,
West Virginia,
whatever they're out of mind out of the
[inaudible] 65.
Yeah,
they were doing it back then.
People been fucking their kids.
I'm not there since that's what,
twenties.
Okay.
No.
What,
what uh,
uh,
on that story there by saying these are
the wrong questions.
I'm saying by saying no mess.
Kind of new.
So,
so what,
uh,
what's the right question?
Well,
the right questions are,
well,
here's,
here's what's wrong questions because
all of this is eye witness testimony,
which is the absolute worst,
most unreliable piece of evidence.
You should.
Yet,
I was in awe.
How many guys on death row,
et Cetera,
because I witnessed when I was in
Alberta,
a hunting bear.
The first time I was up there,
I thought I saw a wolf.
It was a squirrel,
but for two seconds I thought it was a
fucking wolf because I saw in the woods,
I saw it moving through this incredibly
dense brush and I'm like,
Oh shit,
it's a wolf.
It's a squirrel.
What the fuck is wrong with me?
Because I was scared.
My senses were heightened.
I was looking in the wall.
We'll confer a wolf and because they are
a little bit that squirreled didn't
commit.
Any crime in your mind starts to feel
that is Max.
That is not the wolf that stole my
money.
That is a squirrel.
You're on it.
You're buying fills in blanks and they I
believe that.
No,
it absolutely does happen and people
have put suggestions into people's head
and then put them in certain situations
and then they're mine actually sees
things that aren't there.
Your mind fills in blanks.
Also when you have memories of things,
if your memory's correspond with other
people's memories,
you'll adjust your memories to
correspond to an iconic or archetypal
type of story that people were passing
around.
And so if you have a story that emanates
from one particular region and one guy
shows up at the corner store and he
goes,
man,
you ain't going won't believe this.
I saw a dude with moth wings.
It's a man who was a moth.
Like Holy Shit,
you hear about Bob,
he's all mouth man.
And then people started getting crazy
and they're sitting around drinking and
the next thing you know,
pd saw them off,
man,
I was coming home,
I was leaving the bar,
I was all mad.
And all of a sudden I saw a man with
moth's wings and I stopped thinking
about my own troubles.
And I said,
man,
this might be a demonic area.
We've got pitch.
And the next thing you know another dude
sees the moth man,
then it spreads.
And then those stories are,
they become 10 years old and 20 years
old and it goes on and on and on.
People are full of Shit.
But the very specific time it was for
one year,
people were seeing all these mosman or
one moth man,
right?
And then same time
there's Ufos in this area,
and then people were being visited by
men and black,
and then this bridge collapsed and they
believed that the moth man is some sort
of banshee that shows up to warn people
that,
uh,
something terrible is about to happen.
It seems totally logical.
Come on,
just fill in the blanks.
Oh,
there's the mafia man.
he's up there.
Oh,
look at that.
Those are the gargoyle.
That's not,
that's the mouth man,
Bro.
Now that's fake photo.
You know what's fake?
You know,
look,
I mean just the Jersey Devil.
Here's another one.
Jersey Devil.
Do you ever see the journey?
I like to do a show where,
where I go,
I take out like luxury,
like that Jersey Devil remind me.
So,
so I want to take out other other
filmmakers.
Like if Jersey Devil,
I get Kevin Smith and go go in a tent
and go look for the Jersey Devil.
Don't you think that's a great idea?
It might come on.
It might be funny.
Did you remember what was that?
Monster show was the monster.
She got all that,
but I liked the idea that like this is,
yeah,
but this is just,
you know,
this,
this is just a reason to get guys who
shouldn't be out in the woods.
Do you know what I mean?
Right,
right.
Take,
take steven soderbergh out looking for
the swamp ape.
You know what I mean?
We're not the most robust gentleman.
Right?
We're not the adventures.
Oh,
please.
But if you really do think there's
storytellers,
well that's one of the reasons why Les
Stroud becomes interesting because less
drought is add two experiences and one
of them that he is pretty adamant.
Yeah.
I had a bit of bear,
couldn't have been anything else and he
really believes that it was a sasquatch
to the point where he's dedicated weeks
and weeks to going out into the woods
and,
but hanging out with a known charlatan,
the guys hanging out with is a total
bull sharks.
I'm sure you've seen this show.
Have you seen bigfoot show with a guy?
Wears the mask in,
pretends he's big foot now.
He's never seen the footage of what I,
that last drought is hanging around
with.
Oh No.
Put a fucking mask on and got close up.
Video footage of him standing there even
blinking with this fintech.
Is it Shabaka mask?
I don't know what kind of basket is.
It's so fake.
It hurts my feelings.
It hurts my feelings when I watch it I
go,
oh my God,
they fly because I have children and
that it makes me think this is someone's
kid who grew up and he's now he's this
fucking stupid that he made.
This video will get it.
That's it.
Back there.
Look at this as if this thing is just
hanging out.
And by the way,
this guy who made this,
according to the big foot researchers,
he's got a history with having problems
with reality.
And so wait till you see the fucking,
when they zoom in it's like,
oh,
is it there?
Cause it,
they're all thinking,
I've seen this pretending it's an actual
declerk squatch hold on,
wait till he get cultural feel like this
is is a hold 100% real.
I just try to zoom in it.
Oh,
there it is.
Oh my God.
He's looking at me.
I can't believe it.
My blood turned cold.
I'll start,
uh,
getting goosebumps all across my arm and
I was looking at him and I realized this
cannot be a man in a suit.
It's too good.
I got bad.
That is Kamala Furry is,
it's like someone was like one of those
hats that like really rich old ladies
wear when we're walking down fifth
avenue.
How do you argue with stupid?
That is stupid.
It is.
Oh my God,
look at that one even better.
Watch it.
Watch it blank.
We've heard that's like,
you know,
it's real.
It's fucking real bobcat of blank.
Look how it's quaff to luke.
His hair's combed like fonzie.
And I hear that a lot.
It looks like Fabian that he's got
hairspray on.
Then,
um,
that very clean.
Come on.
Get the fuck out.
Right.
Look at that.
Well that obviously clearly that fake as
fuck.
No,
that's fake.
Yeah.
I'm not going to survive.
Or Man,
Les Stroud is a friend of mine had that
fucking,
they put that shit on the show and he
had some like so big.
It's not like a caveat like what does he
say?
He doesn't,
it's still,
does he say that that's real.
It all becomes very problematic when yo
money tied into whether you can't talk
too much shit cause it's on his show.
He makes money off that show.
By the way,
that Survivorman bigfoot massive ratio.
It gets bigger ratings than regular
survivor man.
Like we dropped some stuff off and
fucking Africa by himself with a butter
knife like that.
That's impressive.
That's,
he's done some real aim and that doesn't
get nearly the ratings at this hanging
out with his fake bigfoot guy does,
you know?
Well it's weird man.
Well so,
so well they,
they buried there.
There,
there maybe.
See,
I talked to a,
this guy todd does hotel,
who's a biologist and we did some tests
on all these different things that
people thought were big foot shit,
big foot hair.
It's all bears.
Bears are dogs or coyotes or something
like that.
But all of it we did actual for that
team.
We have,
yeah,
we all went to a real lab at Nyu,
did a real tests.
It's all bullshit.
There's nothing,
there's not one piece of evidence.
And then there was that lady who was
that lady from Texas who was calling
their name DNA.
Yeah.
They all got to catch him.
Catch him.
She was saying that she found DNA that
had,
it was some sort of nonhuman primate.
It's bullshit.
It's tainted.
But she's um,
she's kind of ostracized in the big
football.
They've cast her aside.
That's how you know you're full of shit.
The big foot communities,
like this bitch is too crazy for us.
Kick rocks.
Melba.
Yeah.
It's telling you're a fucking horse shit
over here.
Go Penalty.
Who?
You better have your shoe bags.
So,
uh,
all right,
we're not going to agree on that.
That's why I've been,
listen,
I don't discount the possibility that
not only did that animal exist,
but maybe even could still exist because
the Pacific northwest,
incredibly dense.
It's a massive event.
It's a weird environment part.
That's actually the part,
one of the things when you get out there
and you truly,
I mean they lose planes in there.
Oh yeah.
And they don't find them.
You,
you can be,
I've been in places where I'm like,
I'm not,
I'm lost.
And you know what I mean?
Like,
and it's a question of like 10,
15 feet like that dense.
It's crazy.
So that's what that is
about.
Insane amounts of acreage that people
just don't live in from Oregon all the
way down the northern California ranch.
So I mean,
that's the part that,
uh,
when I started going around and I went
in that deep,
I was like,
wow,
this is,
it's crazy how remote that is.
It makes it compelling.
But the,
the,
the shitty stories,
the fake footage,
the fake footprints,
all the fakeness.
It makes me wonder if you're just
dealing with a myth that is kind of cool
to talk about because it exists in this
very strange environment.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I totally agree that I love,
I do.
And since I was a kid,
I'm always been fascinated by these
different kinds of characters and,
and who are they and what,
uh,
what do they mean to us?
Yeah.
And that's really key.
I mean,
I'll be writing a screenplay that it has
nothing to do with Frankenstein.
And I realized later on,
I was like,
oh,
I was,
this was Frankenstein.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
This is someone who,
who was rebuilt after being marred and
became,
you know,
and come to the fire and became this
monster that is unstoppable.
And I have to get finished writing.
And I go,
oh,
I just wrote Frankenstein,
goddammit.
You know?
So,
um,
I,
you know,
and I'm fascinated by,
by that.
Well,
it's,
it's also the fact that native Americans
don't really have a lot of fake animals
in their folklore.
There's not a lot of,
but this one is incredibly prevalent.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I really think it has to do with jug and
Opeth Agus and if you follow where Chai
Candle pithiness was,
Jack [inaudible] was in Asia and uh,
just like all the other animals came
across the bering strait,
right.
If they did come across the bering
shape,
they would be exactly in the area where
the sightings are from Alaska all the
way down the Pacific northwest,
Vancouver,
northern bc,
those are the areas where you have the
BC rockies,
those are areas you have the most
sidings.
So,
but those are areas where the bears are,
you know,
it's the same range as these black bear.
So I think it's entirely possible that
at one point in time there was something
like that that made it over here along
with um,
with human beings.
And you believe that,
um,
this is um,
like,
um,
I just sense memory that has gone from
generation to generation.
I think he's just stories that get
passed down and those stories become in
our head and then we go looking for it.
And I think it's entirely possible that
written language is like how long has,
how long has spoken language been around
for?
I want to say,
I want to say it's like 40,000 years,
but I might be wrong.
I think,
I think language is like,
it was spoken language is like 40,000
years old,
which is not really that long.
So the,
which means spoken language most likely
was around somewhere around the time
that animal exists.
It's like if they didn't know that
gigantic pithy is a gigantic pithiness
existed at all until the 1920s and the
bones that they got from this one area
were dated at about a hundred thousand
years old.
It's entirely feasible that these
animals could have survived another 30,
40,
50,
who knows how many thousands of years
until it eventually became extinct.
So if that's the case,
I think people probably experienced
them.
They probably came in contact with them.
Um,
and um,
there's also,
there was a bunch of different bears
that existed.
Uh,
was it a flathead or a flat face bear?
I forget what it's called.
Flat nose bear flat face bear.
But it was a prehistoric bear that
existed in the place to scene that,
um,
was,
uh,
such a formidable Predator,
apparently according to Dan Flores,
that he thinks it impeded the progress
of people from Asia to North America.
There was a huge,
like the biggest barrier,
like as big as a Kodiak Grizzly,
so that these enormous bears,
flathead bear,
Short face bear.
That's it.
Wow.
Look at the size of this fucking thing.
I mean,
this is an absolutely enormous bear.
That was the Apex Predator of North
America that went extinct.
Uh,
find out when it,
when it's double the size of it,
like a big,
they were,
I mean,
it's a fucking monstrous,
monstrous,
predatory animal.
And did this animal,
was the preeminent a Predator in North
America?
And what year was that?
Not that long ago.
I mean,
while humans were alive for sure.
Wow.
Yeah.
Let's,
um,
find out when it went extinct.
It's a 11,000 years ago.
That ain't shit,
nothing and shit.
So that would also be,
especially if it like the black bear and
like many grizzlies walks on two legs.
Right?
So if that thing was out there walking
around on two legs,
that would,
you know,
native Americans,
native Americans have some weird
relationships with bears too.
It's one of the few animals that they
refuse to hunt.
They don't,
they don't hunt them.
And a lot of the first nation people up
in Canada,
like I have a buddy of mine who lives up
in Canada and he hunts bears and he
trades with first nation people.
They won't hunt bears,
but they want bear fat for their
medicine and they use it to make pies
and a bunch of different things.
You're like Bayer Lard.
It's like very prized.
But they,
why weren't they smell weird religious
stuff like [inaudible] or do they play
drum stuff?
They believe guys like an ancestor
that's coming back.
All right.
I have some,
some interesting ideas about their
answers are delicious.
Yeah,
well the kids good if they eat the right
foods.
If you find a bear that's a coastal bear
that's been eating a lot of salmon,
they're not fun to eat because they eat
a lot of rotten fish and they taste
terrible apparently.
But the bears that I've eaten,
I've only been the ones that live in
these dense woods and their diets were
part of the country,
Alberta.
That's where you go bear at northern
Um,
mostly what they're eating is berries
and twit end each other.
Unfortunately,
really 100%.
That's one of the big things about bears
is that especially the males,
which is the ones you go after and kill,
they eat cubs.
Wow.
Yeah.
Like all of them do.
It's like one of the main things they go
looking for once they come out of
hibernation.
Wow.
All apologies to my dead.
Yeah.
And there's been a lot worse hours and
there's two theories about the cutting.
Have another bobby,
if I cry,
I'm so full.
It's a awful,
it happened when we were there two years
ago.
One of our,
uh,
one of one of the guys who was a guide
there saw,
we saw two bears fight.
I saw with my own eyes a bear trying to
kill this,
a females cubs.
And she fought him off and she kept
fighting him off and he kept coming in
and she kept fighting off.
Meanwhile,
her babies were up in trees,
the babies ran up and trees like we were
watching her move around and she was
kind of aware of us,
but we were far enough away from our
work and we weren't moving where she
didn't think we were a threat,
but then all of a sudden the baby bears,
they,
they piped up and they fucking just ran
up a tree and we were like,
what the fuck's going on in this big
male bear came in and the two of them
just started duking it out and they were
like,
it was like a UFC fight 50 yards away
and should me these two bears,
I mean,
they'd go on a war.
It was crazy.
It was really fascinating.
It was too dark even for us to shoot the
big male bear because it was just,
it was,
was enough visibility wouldn't be
ethical to do,
but it was fascinating to watch.
Like she was protecting her babies from
predication,
from another band and she,
and she scared it up.
But here's what happened.
I'm not with this bear,
but in that same time we were there,
one bear came in and one of the guides
saw it happen,
got ahold of one of the cubs,
killed it in front of everybody was
eating it,
then she chased him off and then she
finished her own cub.
Uh,
it's a hard scrabble world up there
living in the woods of northern Canada.
It's no joke.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's no joke.
It's scary shit.
And so that's the reality of these
animals and the population up there is
insane.
There's so many of them when people,
yeah.
When people think like they think,
Oh,
you're killing bears,
why would you kill bears?
There's not even that many barriers.
You got to go to Alberta.
There's a lot of fucking bears.
There's,
they're all over the place.
Like it's not uncommon on a day up there
to see 18 bears.
Wow.
We've seen we've more than other days.
It's crazy.
Wow.
You always see bears.
You always see him when you go hunting
for bears,
the success rate is very high and the,
the population is very high.
And also they encourage it.
They want you to kill two large males.
That's like,
will they give you a tag to kill two of
them?
Right.
Because they're killing all of these
cubs and because,
or,
um,
fonz rather they're killing moose
calves,
elk calves and,
and deer fawns they wipe out more than
50% of all the baby moose,
baby deer and baby a elk.
Um,
a moose.
Yeah.
Do you ever see them?
Oh yeah,
there was a moose.
Dad Is,
Oh really?
Yeah,
that's a juvenile was,
yeah,
that was used,
I think it was 900 pounds.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's funny,
like none of this sets me off.
And then,
you know,
and I said,
cause I mean,
this is what I grew up with.
There was always,
there was,
I remember once my brother,
you know,
he would,
uh,
clean the deer in the garage and he had
this idea that he was going to take the
skin off.
Uh,
so he likes me,
like he sliced the,
you know,
he was going to peel the skin off of the
year,
will the truck,
his Volkswagen.
Okay.
So he hooked it up and then it just
snapped
year and a half star
dark.
Yeah.
Maybe that's why I'm a Vegan and you
know,
and I'm gonna like tiny little boy,
you know,
calm.
He's in the garage,
you know,
dismantling Rudolph with is Volkswagen
bug.
Um,
I had this conversation with these guys
from this,
this documentary cowspiracy and it was
all like really heavy and it's really
like,
um,
about factory farming,
which I think is disgusting.
And I think pretty much everybody does.
And The AG gag laws,
which are even more disgusting,
which are these laws that are in place
to keep you from taking video footage of
any,
uh,
harm atrocities.
And then I went home and I turned on
that Steve Rinella guys show and he was
showing how to butcher a deer.
And one of the ways they did it was they
take like a rock and they wrapped the
hide up in this rock and then tie it off
and then tie that rope on that rock to a
truck and then pull it.
And it just looks so fucked up.
Is deer hanging by?
It's like honches.
Yeah.
And then they just strip the skin off of
it,
have like a sheet and they're like,
oh,
is it safe and safe?
And then they're cutting it up and
slicing it and turning it into roasts
and chops and steaks and hamburger meat
and like,
whoa.
It just,
the cold reality of what meat is and
where it comes from,
which has escaped us.
It is like it left the consciousness of
most people who eat meat,
they don't experience it.
They don't see it.
It's like,
it's one of the things that's insidious,
um,
about a lack of information because of
the lack of information changes,
the actual context.
It changes what a thing is to you.
It's one of the things I think is really
devious about what the Bush
administration did when they pass laws
that kept people from taking photographs
of coffins.
Just coffee.
Yes.
They made a law against press taking
photos around.
Yeah.
Which is crazy because they're not only,
they are,
they're filtering and controlling the
narrative so much that you can't even
see an American flag draped coffin.
Yeah.
It's very dark because then I remember
when name mind.
Yeah.
In your mind only means war.
If you lost your friend or if you lost
your husband,
or if you've lost your wife,
then it becomes war.
But if it's just somebody you don't even
know,
then it allows you to just keep going on
number.
And it's,
it's,
it's just a number and it's very,
yeah.
I mean,
what,
you know,
one of the things that got us out of
Vietnam was the,
the footage that was on the news every
night when you're having dinner and you,
you know,
that,
that was what ended it.
I mean,
what do I know?
But that,
that felt like when I handed it to me.
Yeah.
Well look,
it's,
here we are 15 years later,
we're still in Afghanistan.
Yeah.
Why?
And there's never any footage Navarro.
And when I was a kid,
when I was at a kid,
that was what was on during the news
while we're having dinner.
And that was what I saw my parents turn,
you know,
my parents went from cursing hippies and
per war protesters to go into the other
side.
Wow.
You know,
so it must have been interesting.
Yeah,
I mean,
I watched it,
you know,
and so yeah,
the fact that the,
uh,
I remember when,
when,
when that happened when we was crazy.
But I think the new administration is
going to fix everything for sure.
Especially if trump wins.
Yeah.
Very excited about that.
If Hillary Clinton wins,
she's going to,
it's going to be all different folks.
It's not going to be business as usual.
It's not going to be just politics,
not going to be about money controlling
politics.
It's not,
I don't care where she gets her money
from,
dude.
She's got ethics,
she's got oils.
Those bankers,
they could pay her hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
She's going to tell them off.
Yeah,
it is.
But it isn't an insane camp.
And this is a,
I've never seen anything like this.
I'm 53 years old,
most insane.
Right.
Barry must be loving it.
You know,
it's funny.
It's got father three because Barry was
out,
you know,
and they dragged him back.
You know,
it's so crazy that he had to get back
in.
Yeah.
He was like up in the woods.
Yeah,
I know.
Isn't it great.
It's kind of funny.
So we all get a gift from that.
Highlights how the system
is that this is all it needs is a two
party system and the in the,
yeah,
and the fact that it's not one man,
one vote.
And you know,
there's a whole lot of that.
But this is also like what does our
society become?
Our society's become this crazy thing
where we pay attention to whatever
spectacles on the news.
Yeah.
Well that's spectacles.
Now a guy who's running for president
when plastic hair.
Yeah.
That guy.
That's a reality star though.
You're fired.
You know those Mexicans are going to
build us a wall.
The Wall just got 10 foot higher.
The morons at fucking up in arms like we
got in quicker fucker takeover.
And it's exciting.
It's a white people are very excited to,
it's a,
yeah,
like white men.
Let's make America white again.
White men.
And I mean ladies and ladies that like
trump all buttoned down,
angry faces,
thin lips like this.
And it tells so interesting to the
Republicans trying to knock out him,
which is crazy to what can they do?
I mean,
what do they,
what do they have left?
I don't know.
It's just running.
Yeah.
Mic didn't work,
Dev.
Nothing.
Nobody's ever said quick.
Give me a mormon.
Could you hear about the guy who,
who,
um,
who was writing a blogger who is writing
a piece about Ted Cruz's connection?
His father's connection to the death of
Lee Harvey Oswald that apparently Ted
Cruz's father was involved in some way
with the death of Lee Harvey Oswald.
Not only that,
he may have played a part of in the
assassination attempt with,
uh,
President Kennedy.
He might have had a part in the
assassination of President Kennedy,
Ted Cruz,
his fucking dad.
So take parents is dance connection Jack
Ruby.
Yes.
And just some sort of a connection with
the,
uh,
the people that were rebelling against
the Battista regime and the like,
a lot of his story apparently is
bullshit.
And like,
people who have looked into it,
and it's one of the things that they
were looking into while he was running
for president.
They're like his dad.
It doesn't,
here's the story of his dad.
His Dad came over on a raft with $100
sewn into his underwear.
I get one of those stories and he made
it with good old fashioned American
ingenuity.
Hmm.
Apparently not.
Apparently he was like a rebel,
you know,
he may have played a part in the death
of Lee Harvey Oswald.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well there was a guy who was writing the
story about it and he wound up dead.
Wow.
Yeah.
And you know,
the guy even wrote,
Hey,
if,
uh,
if I'm not around anymore,
you know,
this is what happened and this is the
story.
But people do that kind of shit before
they killed themselves.
That's,
that's your problem.
Because they think there's a real story.
And one of the things that they're all
depressed,
and I think one of the things that I'm
gonna do,
I'm gonna make this story happened.
I'll blow my brains out and they're
going to think that,
you know,
they're going to look into this because
they're going to think that I was
whacked by the demand.
Like as if anybody is running around
killing people over Lee Harvey Oswald's
death today.
Was that Jamie?
These are the photos that they found of
Ted Cruz's dad.
Yeah.
That's the guy in the white shirt here.
That's Ted Cruz's dad.
This was an unidentified man,
uh,
from the Warren Commission.
So they think that that's him.
Oh,
it looks like I'm Cuban Fella and
there's a couple of pictures of it.
But uh,
yeah,
that's,
that's the link.
Hmm.
Most likely I'm going with that.
I'm going to run with it.
So it looks like now
that's him today.
Well,
apparently you,
his story doesn't add up when they,
um,
they check out the,
the,
his history when he says he got here.
Well,
when he actually was here,
there's a lot of a funky business.
And by the way,
I have a fucking very,
very shallow knowledge of this story.
I leafed over today.
Cruiser spawns.
Yes.
My dad killed JFK secret la Elvis.
And Jimmy Hoffa is buried in his
backyard.
Aw.
Ty got sunk by that video that showed
the outtakes of him making one of those
videos.
Oh,
did you see that?
I,
no,
no family and his mom fantastic.
Like it was a,
one of them was like,
you know,
my mom prays for me oftentimes hours a
day,
and she went like,
like that.
His mom like,
well I don't fucking pray for you.
Hours a day will come.
What am I crazy?
Jesus Christ.
They made them do take after take.
There it is.
It was like so it's so vague.
We can't hear without the headset on.
There's his dad.
He killed JFK.
Heard.
Want to hear it here?
I'll put the headset off.
Earlier this year,
the Cruz campaign posted hours of this
footage on youtube by law campaigns
can't coordinate with super pacs.
So many quietly post rock videos like
this on public websites as a way to
share material legally,
but it lets us take a rare peek behind
the scenes at this strange world of
political ad making to me a couple lines
from Munich.
Ah,
that's true.
Personal tip.
I don't want to tell that I do like it.
I'll like it in a box.
I'll like it in a goat.
I'll like it.
You're the best person to tell him.
Well,
there's some very personal details that
I don't want to go into.
I don't like it.
I don't like,
I'm Sam.
I am.
When Ted was three,
look at me.
I need the buck of you want to give me
specific lines,
but not a day goes by that my mom is not
lifting me up in prayer for hours at a
time.
Ah,
country today.
Am I supposed to say like the same type?
My family background,
my grandfather was a missionary in
Africa for about 40 years.
I don't know what else was saying.
I don't know.
Talking she keeps looking at a kid for a
kid is fucking crazy,
dad.
The brother thinks too much.
I can't get as Gig down.
He's gonna live there.
It seems like everything is staged.
Even hugs,
hubs.
We're out of your joy.
I love you.
Oh
No.
Who's that guy?
I love you too.
I love your mom.
Oh Gee,
do I love you?
Oh,
fake happy.
I love you.
I killed JFK.
He got right in his ear.
This is the same as what we're talking
about.
Lime.
Yeah,
this is big.
I love you will be big fun.
Look at this.
They're sitting around the dinner table.
Just didn't even know a camera's there.
Camera just caught us.
It's weird.
Wow.
Let's hold hands in prayer.
Dear magic man in the sky,
who doesn't let people,
let's make sure that our food is all
been blessed to suggest a casual,
uh,
you know,
we say grace first.
We laid the Dolly track out.
First of all,
why are you pretending this is your
fucking kitchen table bitch?
You know,
you got some Nice House.
You got cash,
you got to live in a simple humble life.
Fuck.
We were looking at before you got here,
something that I forgot about.
Can we play that?
What?
Um,
I forgot about this and recently I was
doing a show and then they stand up show
and the guy in the booth played at Avery
and um,
in my mind it was lot,
lot.
It was way more chill.
This is Arsenio Hall got canceled and
uh,
this is footage of me going on the show.
Great.
What I want to know,
do I have to keep giving your app?
Okay.
This is after he's canceled.
Yeah.
Why am I getting easier for the next
guy?
Are you really quitting?
Yeah.
No,
he spray painted on his sack.
What is it?
What are you saying?
Per Paramount.
Paramount sucks.
Yeah.
Uh,
I don't even remember this.
and now nobody stopped you.
So really did not know I was going to do
this.
Oh,
did they know you had a can in your
pocket?
No.
No,
no.
After this,
I would start getting patted down when I
did show,
and this is before,
but this,
this,
this boy that tonight,
tonight,
show on fire.
See through h coat couch cushions to
the,
what is this though?
This is,
oh my God,
you took smashed.
It's $3,000 minded.
Or they make you,
they charge you for that?
Yeah.
They were nice.
Leno charged me for the chair.
He did?
Yeah.
How much did he charge you for the
chance?
It's like 500 bucks isn't like that.
Oh my God,
dude,
you're going crazy.
This is so punk rock,
Arsenio stepping in and try to stop you.
But he's laughing while he's doing that.
But here it's funny.
This is hilarious.
I liked how you kept your hat on the
damn board.
Yeah.
But here's the funny as,
Oh yeah,
it get stopped here.
But they just,
when they broadcast it,
they put this logo at.
Yeah,
that's it.
But so,
uh,
when they broadcast that,
they put that logo up because the
director at the time just had this
loving shot push into paramount sucks.
Oh,
that's good.
They had a problem with,
but when he wrestled me down,
he actually,
he whispers into my heroes.
Is there going to commercially I guess.
Thanks man.
So then,
yeah,
then Leno booked me,
uh,
like four days after.
That's hilarious.
Cause of that is set on fire.
That's what they want.
I was just,
I was more angry I think at j,
but,
but yeah,
he's like,
no,
you know what happened over in Athenian?
And I go,
well,
you angry Jay for I eat my ego and I,
you know,
he and fear,
he suddenly was having me on the show
that was going on the show and people
seemed like they liked me in the idea of
being accepted on such a mass level was
terrifying.
And I think I resented him because even
though he's older than me,
I've been doing comedy almost the same
amount of time.
And he was always kind of always like
doling out advice and it's like,
well,
I don't want to have your career,
you know,
I don't do it that I think that,
and it's like,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm a man and I make my decisions.
I just do a different kind of comedies.
You,
I'm not criticizing the kind of comedy,
you know,
you guys do.
You know,
there's all those sweater acts back
then,
you know,
and uh,
so,
and,
and I,
I don't regret it,
but I do think I was kind of an asshole
move to j.
It was an aggressive movement.
And I,
and I apologize to him later on,
years later,
I was like,
I was being nasty.
We're j belongs to what he's doing now.
I'm sorry.
No,
no,
no.
Go ahead.
Jay belongs is what he's doing now.
Like doing that car show.
He's fucking great at it.
He's great on it.
It's fun.
Different guy.
But he's a funny guy.
I mean,
yeah,
that Letterman,
you mean he would crush?
Yeah.
And um,
I haven't seen the car show.
Well a lot of comics felt betrayed
because he was this guy who was kind of
like the hips smart voice of like
marketing a lot of the stupid shit that
we saw in the world.
And then all of a sudden he gets his
tonight show Gig and he becomes Mr
Living Room.
Yeah.
And he was,
he went from,
yeah,
I mean it looks like I'm pinging fire.
They actually,
um,
so he's got this show now.
I think it's funny,
like in my memory I was like,
well that's just the little fire.
But that's a pretty good,
see this is cause I have lighter fluid.
That's what made it arson cause it was
premeditated.
I learned a lot of being in the moment.
Well,
I mean if I just set it on fire with a
lighter,
then yeah,
this was,
that's why it was arson.
But anyway,
he's showed that he's doing now.
It's like something that he actually
cares about and we talked about it.
I had him on the podcast.
He was like,
yeah,
I mean I would have these,
you know,
he couldn't pick who's on the tonight
show.
So they would put people on like from
reality shows and he'd be like,
he'd have to say,
you and Harry,
are you going to get married?
Yeah.
That's the nature of that.
It's uh,
you know,
I think letterman made a decision after,
some days I think,
I'm paraphrasing,
but someone said,
well,
who was on the show tonight?
And he's like,
I don't know.
And then he was like,
I got it.
Yeah.
That was when he decided to retire.
Like he couldn't remember.
I get that when I used to direct the
Kimmel show.
Someone say who was on last night and I
couldn't remember.
Yeah.
Because it's a grind.
It's weird.
Yeah.
It's a weird gig.
When you're doing,
is fascinated by the ego of the guy.
Remember the guy who tried to blackmail
letterman?
Yeah.
Well he was fucking the guy's girlfriend
or whatever it was.
Letterman had had some sort of
relationship and now this guys has a
relationship.
My,
you know,
my take on it was this guy couldn't get
past that.
She used to bang and probably,
and some of the,
and he was going through a bad divorce,
so he's like,
I got this thing.
I'm going to blackmail letter men and
let his current girlfriend,
I don't,
I think the woman who became his wife
about this,
he's going to blow up the whole thing.
And I love that letterman what the guy
never ever,
ever thought of.
What if the guy just does the right
thing?
Yeah.
Let him and just said,
hey,
you know,
this happened.
Went on TV.
Yeah.
It was beautiful.
And it didn't become a story like the
way it normally would,
and he didn't do that bullshit fake.
I did something wrong.
He said,
this is between my wife and I,
but someone's blackmail.
I mean it just,
you know,
cause cause,
cause I always,
that pho apology is really strange.
Like for,
for nothing.
You know,
like,
um,
when hugh grant apologize,
he said,
well I did a bad thing.
It's like well w did you and would,
if you hadn't been arrested,
what do you said,
hey I did a bad thing last night.
I didn't get arrested anything,
but you guys should know I picked up a
hooker at.
Right.
You know what I mean?
You wouldn't,
it's so it's,
what do you apologize?
So,
but letterman didn't do a pho apology.
He just did the right thing and he,
and the guy's life came down like a
house of cards and I,
and I think it was in jail.
Yeah.
And I think when you're like,
I think as a young man,
you can't get past your partner's
history,
you know,
and this guy,
I just think,
I don't know,
there's something really poetic.
I don't know.
I'm,
I'm fascinated by the story cause I,
the twist is all David Letterman did was
the right thing.
And that was shocking to this guy and
almost to our society.
We couldn't do anything with it.
We couldn't exploit it.
Couldn't sell people magazine when
somebody just square.
He also did it the way he confessed on
television.
He did it like a David letterman
conversation.
Well yeah.
Um,
I was having sex with
someone to work with me.
Yeah.
And everybody's like,
what the fuck is he doing?
I love that I spent so much time on all
this trying to manage stuff and staying
instead of actually owning something
instead of saying this is what I did,
this is what I did wrong.
Um,
it's really knowing your business.
Yeah.
Well it's like when we catch someone
lying about something and then they're
there,
they're deceptive.
That's when people get like really into
something.
But when someone comes out and just owns
it,
like Charlie Sheen,
like when he went on all these shows and
tell,
yeah,
I smoke rocks.
That's what you do.
You know,
I,
I smoke all this coke,
you know,
cause uh,
that's how I roll baby.
Everybody's like,
well,
I fucking love this guy.
But meanwhile,
if someone had footage of him smoking
crack out there,
you know,
Bang and hookers,
people be like,
oh my God,
his career is over.
And he would say,
I got to put a spin on this.
There would be some,
some sort of recovery.
What's really interesting is the Charlie
Sheen thing.
We're finding out that the whole
tailspin that he went through and like
2012 was because he found out he had
HIV.
Like that's really part of what this all
was about.
And that's what the most recent,
uh,
black male,
attempts against him was.
Apparently he's paid millions of dollars
to quiet this down big.
And he had all these sexual partners and
didn't tell them,
I guess or so there's all also of other
lawsuits,
most of the craziness involved.
But that's what set him off.
And what made him say,
fuck it,
I'm just going to go out and tell
everybody everything.
And it was because he had HIV.
It's really nuts.
It's,
um,
I was thinking of someone else's story
at the same time just then.
It's,
I dunno,
I think,
uh,
we're just so used to this filter that,
that I,
uh,
when someone is just genuinely honest
and saying,
um,
you know,
that that is actually the s the most
powerful thing and it takes all the
sting out.
There's no,
you don't get any,
there's no gossip,
right?
You say,
yeah,
I did this.
I think people were way more concerned
with deception.
Then there are,
they are with folly.
They're way more dis concerned with
deception and the are what people
fucking up with people making mistakes
with.
Well,
I think it's funny when,
when,
when people will talk,
I mean not that was a big deal that I
set the leno show and fire,
but people now will come up to me and
say,
um,
there'll be like,
or,
or stories appear that say I was banned
from the tonight show.
And it's like,
no,
it wasn't that you,
you made that step I was on a week
later.
You decided that.
Right,
right.
That's it.
That's a common thing.
And I was of me.
I see people saying that it was banned
for I me,
I was laying,
I was banned for a whole seven days.
You lit it on fire and then we me back
and we'd just say,
hey man,
I'm really,
no,
we did it,
you know,
have you lighting you on fire
now?
He added me back on the show and um,
he asked me,
buried in dirt up to my neck,
you know,
it was funny.
You know,
it's so,
it's like,
no,
it didn't happen.
Right.
It just,
you made the next step,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a common thing.
I think we can connect that to big foot.
The people,
they just make shit up.
Right.
All right.
A way to say,
I don't want saying,
I think look,
look,
like,
like I said,
I would lose sleep for days if big foot
turned out to be true.
I'd be so happy.
I'll say this then,
then,
then that's good.
Look if someone hit one with a car and
he died and they had definitive proof
that there is a real gigantic pythagoras
and you see some fucking,
you know,
blank cruiser that's smashed by some
gigantic ape.
They just wandered out of the forest.
Holy Shit.
I'd be happy.
Just so happy at despondent one.
Yeah.
Well not even if it was,
no,
no.
I just jumped in front of a truck going
through a bad breakup out loud.
But I think that,
I mean I think I could,
I could honestly say it will be one of
the happiest moments in my life if they
found a big foot,
if the captured a big foot.
I mean if we were watching on television
and we were seeing like some footage
from some containment area where they
had these giant steel bars like Kong and
they had this huge 10 foot tall one.
I like your,
I like your Harry and the Hendersons a a
one better I have was it just gets hit
by a car.
I said what happened in Harry?
In the Henderson.
Yeah,
but I'm not sure we'd rather have that
then.
Then this animal sadly captured,
well,
one of my favorite hoax stories is a guy
in Montana.
I'll put a Ghillie suit on.
Oh.
And uh,
tried to fake that he was big foot one
teenager random over one way,
and another teenager ran him over the
other way.
So he got hit on the one side Blam on
one side of the road,
then another teenager the other way,
random over.
And that's hilarious.
You know,
it's like,
well,
he died doing what?
He loves you.
You know what I mean?
Like that funeral I had to be like,
you know?
Yeah.
The chuckles,
the clown,
the Mary Tyler Moore,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
yeah,
he was just up trying to fake out the
math.
We're in a Ghillie suit hanging out the
side of the road is going to be funny.
The lamb girl ran him over.
She saw a big foot's just turn the wheel
towards him.
Bam.
I think,
uh,
well,
when we find big foot,
when,
how much confidence?
Yeah,
I'll be,
I'll be back on.
You know,
they,
they're talking about using drones,
sending drones.
Mm.
What were those skies,
but you know that the canopy when,
yeah,
you wouldn't believe,
see shit.
That's ridiculous.
That's the only,
really the most compelling thing about
it is that you just,
the,
the territory so dense.
It's so huge and it's nothing,
man.
They don't even have a hair.
Not a single piece of nothing.
Did you ever,
uh,
do you know about Jimmy Stewart's wife,
Jimmy Stewart,
the comedian,
the actor,
a famous actor,
comic guy has his wife smuggled a Yeti
finger out of the inner underpants.
What?
Out of the Himalayas?
You put it in her pussy.
Oh No,
she put it in their underpants,
but we're all in the back.
No,
isn't he or she wasn't wearing these on
the side.
It was like her luggage and she had
like,
oh,
and she's confused and she's,
imagine what she smelled like after she
got home.
Well,
the Odyssey,
you said this finger come on and she
smuggled it.
Uh,
any researcher Peter Byrne learned of
the getting hand and the scalp on
display.
A remote Buddhist monastery.
Yeah.
But when they,
none us than Hollywood actor Jimmy
Stewart.
Uh,
yeah,
his wife's smuggled it.
No.
And then,
and then recently there's been a DNA
study and it's not a Yeti.
It was,
what is it?
It's a Buddhist monks hand.
Is that what it is?
So dude,
yeah,
but um,
I'm more fascinated about Jimmy
Stewart's wife's muck.
Like what she thought was a Yeti and
Jimmy Stewart was part of it.
Well,
how big was the fuck is lauren calling
involved in this big a Yeti's hands
would be,
yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
this,
uh,
this monk,
he had a big hands.
Well that was another thing about it
yet.
Hold on.
Look at this.
Jamie.
Google this.
There was a,
um,
they found one of the,
one of the reasons why people saw a Yeti
is that there was a bear in the
Himalayas that was thought to be long
extinct.
And it turns out that it may not be,
and it was a different kind of your
Asian bear,
some large base.
Is it a,
is it a white bear?
I mean,
is it like a polar bear?
I don't know.
But you know,
look,
when you're looking at things in the
snow was fascinating to me.
Once I was,
I was,
I was in the woods with these guys and
there's the,
we're looking at trail cam footage and
there's a,
this almost looks like a weasel.
It's called a merit and it was supposed
to be extinct.
And so this guy showing me this footage
and uh,
he,
she goes,
well,
yeah,
this is a merit.
You know,
there hasn't been one in 50 years and
this and that.
And he goes,
but take a look at the snow.
He buries the lead and he goes,
this looks like a footprint.
He clicks past it.
It's like he,
he showed me all this footage,
so you've found that I shouldn't do this
down here.
This must be extinct.
Yeah,
it's a merit.
And then he'd click,
click,
take a look at this.
You know,
we're looking at a footprint in snow and
not concentrating on the fact that he
found an extinct animal.
Swear to God.
I was like this,
you're burying the lead.
You found an animal that was supposed to
be dead.
But we're looking at white might be big
foot duke.
What did he absolutely identify
that as a merit though.
Yeah.
Wow.
So this was a huge news.
Then he,
he,
he didn't seem to give a rat's ass.
So did he report it?
Yeah,
he did.
So now they know this animal is an
extinct.
Exactly.
Well,
there's been some cases,
yeah.
But you know what I mean?
Oh,
that happens a lot.
But yeah,
I mean,
my point is,
is this is the thing,
as much as I love the big foot
community,
I don't know if you've ever gone and
tried to get them to talk about anything
else,
then I'll talk about anything else.
They can't.
It's all of a sudden it's like,
it's like,
it's really weird.
Like if you bring up something,
say,
Hey,
do you guys see the new yeah.
Adventures movie.
What's so compelling to them?
This is this thing that they'd been
searching with no reward.
There's no reward.
And they keep looking and it never
happened.
Whether it's the women.
Okay.
The,
the big foot community women.
Yeah.
But you know,
they just did it and they're like rupees
in the big foot man.
I told the women that went with me,
I said,
Oh really?
You know,
which just don't,
no neck lines.
You guys aren't going to get out of
there a lot.
You've got a it up.
Yeah,
I really did.
I said I though you haven't gotten any
one of these before.
I don't want to see anyone's figures.
Um,
yeah.
What is the most compelling thing to
you?
Is is eye witness evidence or is there I
love that.
Even if someone's lying to me,
if,
if that's the case,
I,
I don't the listening to someone telling
me a story that,
that uh,
they believe is true.
I don't think it's someone lying.
It's my favorite part of finding big
foot when they go to some town
community,
uh,
some community and some small town and
they start talking to them and the
community center and ask them,
how many of you here have had a big foot
and counter and they know the camera's
there,
sir.
All like
they'll raise their hand.
When we were doing this thing,
I was doing this thing for CBS.
It's called game show in my head and
what it was is we,
it was a game show.
We put this little earpiece in people
and the game shows.
We would send them out into a pre,
we created this scenario.
They didn't know what it was going to be
until they got out there,
so they'd be standing there and then I'd
say,
all right,
here's the deal.
You are a news reporter and you have
been sent here to do report on someone
who has seen a Ufo.
The problem is that person took off,
so you need to find a person on the
street that will admit that they saw a
Ufo and they have to tell you that they
were taking a board that Ufo and probed.
If you can get someone to do that on
camera,
you'll win you and you make the money
because it was like a series of tasks,
right?
Yeah.
They all did it.
Every one of the ass did it.
They all fucking did it.
And I was watching these people and that
was the first draw in what broke the
camel's back to me that a lot of these
stories are bullshit because I was
watching these people come up with these
fucking stories on the fly.
They weren't actors.
They weren't alerted of it in advance
where they prepared a story.
They just,
Hey,
I'm in a bind.
I'm a report.
Right.
We were sent down here and these people
just ran out years ago.
Tom Kenny did that for,
uh,
he would,
ask people,
he was doing the same thing,
saying that there's this new movie
coming out.
It's during Danny to be.
So if he would just keep piling on,
then they go,
oh,
daddy is so funny.
I know it's,
his mother dies.
It's so sad seeing Danny devito that
would just change it.
They would,
yeah,
they were.
Yeah.
It's a,
yeah.
If people find out that they're going to
be interviewed and they find out that
they're on camera,
they will do all kinds of crazy things
to comply with whatever the narrative
is,
is real weird,
man.
And so when you're interviewing people
and ask them about Ufo shows or asked
him about big foot,
just the camera and the fact that you're
filming alone,
it changes the reality of whatever their
story would or wouldn't be.
It,
it changes,
it gets adjusted.
It,
it becomes a giant factor in whatever
the story is.
The fact that there's a camera on them.
Well,
I believe on the other side of things
doing like,
um,
after doing call me lucky,
I learned a lot about,
uh,
and you probably know this,
obviously I already,
most people want to tell you their story
and most people do.
You know what I mean?
If,
if you don't even have to do too much,
you don't have to make someone
uncomfortable.
You don't have to even be probing too
much.
Most people do want to be heard.
Most people will tell you really
personal things.
I'm not talking about Barry,
but I'm talking about the other folks
that supported the move.
Um,
uh,
and I learned when I was doing that doc
that the key was that I had a shut up
and I had a listen,
which as a nightclub comedian was really
hard.
How about that?
Oh shoot.
I got to wrap up.
I was,
okay.
Well let me just bring up this topic.
You're on the road a lot.
When guys come in,
the end,
women,
they come in the green room and there,
you know,
you're in their club,
you're in their home town and there's a
whole bunch of local guys and they're
nice and stuff.
But when they start talking about
standup,
does it bore you to tears or are you
engaged in it?
Um,
it really depends.
Like who's coming in the green room.
Other comics.
Yeah.
They,
they want to come up and they want to
start talking to me about comedy and
talking smack about other comics and I'm
laying,
I'm like,
if you have any idea how much I'm
checked out right now,
well for me the real problem is like
green rooms before a show.
Yeah.
I'm trying to get my head together.
I'm not really in talking to anybody.
I'm into going over my notes.
Yeah.
Figuring I want to do with the show.
So if someone comes in and they get in
the way,
like that's my goal,
you actually say,
hey man,
step out.
I don't usually have very many people
really.
I am,
I'm always hosting this thing.
I don't know what it is.
And I'm always just like,
I,
I'll tell,
I will talk about anything other than
that.
And,
and,
and I shouldn't admit this publicly,
but,
but when people come up to me and they
bring up police academy,
Swell,
yeah.
Often,
often I'm,
I'm,
I'm thinking of committing Harry caray
while they're talking to me and I'm not
even kidding you.
Like I said,
oh,
that's great.
How old were you when you saw it?
And I'm just thinking that,
um,
I know I'm really,
and I'm pulling my end trails out under
their shoes.
That's the thought that carries you
through the conversation.
It makes me laugh.
Like I'm thinking.
Yeah.
I'm thinking,
oh,
that's great.
I'm glad you,
I'm glad you liked it.
And I'm just thinking that I'm pulling
my small intestine all over their feet.
Know there's,
you just kind of eat what you,
we all do.
We all have that meets your factory or
faculty to start talking about most
sure.
Fire.
You're polite.
Yeah.
Oh cool man.
Thanks.
I'm glad you like the show.
But then after a while you're like,
you have a lot of people.
It's like when they were kids,
they were like in high school and you
know,
fear factor for me,
they told me how tall they were.
I was this big.
Why?
Why would I give a fuck about how tall
you were when you watch police academy?
Why?
Why,
what?
What do you like talking to comics?
I'm like peers about standup.
Like if you run into someone who's like,
no,
I just shoved it.
Talking about,
it's like,
yeah,
it's like talking about fucking,
it's like,
you know,
you don't like talking about like the
creative process or writing or
roadblocks or motivation or anything
like that?
No,
I just don't like talking about,
it's just,
it's this
thing and it's,
it's,
I don't,
I don't feel like gossiping about it.
I like telling stories.
I love,
I love hearing the funny stories back
and forth.
That's great.
A lot of laughs.
But dissecting comedy for some reason
is,
it's just,
it's,
it's so
uninteresting to me.
That's,
well,
you know,
it's understandable.
I mean,
what'd you start in like 81 or something
like that and when you might start with
15 and 60,
I got let her mom was 20.
How old was,
I mean,
what year was that?
Uh,
it was probably like 80 to,
yeah.
Think about that man.
That is a long fucking time.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean it only makes sense.
He would be born with it,
but,
but you still enjoy doing it.
I do see,
so just started to like it when I
jettison the persona.
I even remember that.
Like I thought I hated,
I thought I hated
the wacky morning shows and you know,
taint and tea bag in the morning and I
thought I hated,
you know.
All right.
That stuff in the clubs and this and
that.
And it's was just like,
oh,
I hate this character.
I,
I remembered the day it happened.
Like it was like an epiphany.
I was at xannies and Nashville's loved
that place and I was like,
I,
and I knew that I couldn't do it.
I had to go on as me
and I made that decision.
And so you went on door yelling,
you know,
do the boy.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it was,
uh,
it changed everything shifted after
that.
And then I started this,
uh,
probably like 10 years ago,
maybe,
maybe longer.
Yeah,
I would say it's probably,
yeah,
around 10 years ago and the,
and it changed for me
and then I liked it again.
That's cool.
Well you,
there's some guys who just get trapped
in a persona.
We were just talking about emo phillips
the other night,
cause emo Philips is apparently back to
his persona.
He let it go for a long time and he just
started just being a guy on stage
talking about shit.
Apparently the people weren't into that.
He's like,
all right,
give the people what they want.
The story I tell about,
I should just clarify this is,
which is what I've heard.
I haven't seen him,
but this is like,
um,
you know,
robin was a,
Williams was my best pal and,
and uh,
he got me a job on,
on,
uh,
a snickers cumbersome and I needed bread
and he was so nice.
He's like,
Oh,
you know,
so I want you to use my friend,
Bobcat,
you know,
he's gotta be in it,
and they're like,
you know,
he actually put their feet on the fire
and they had a hire me and then he goes,
he's like,
don't take the first money.
Just the way,
you know,
tell him no.
So I tell them no.
And then they came back with more than
when I,
you know,
I mean,
he was great.
Right,
right.
So then he calls what,
because you know,
they're going to want you to do the
voice.
Are you okay doing the voice?
And I go for the amount of money
snickers is paying.
I will fuck a snickers behind camera.
By the way,
I should say it's really good candy,
but it's my all time favorite.
You know,
I,
I said I was going to go,
but there's something,
well,
we'll address a little bit and talk
about,
you know,
robin had,
um,
his,
his coroner's report came out and he had
lewy body dementia and that is a,
it's a form of dementia that is very
rarely ever discovered when someone's
alive.
It's usually discovered in there.
They're a autopsy.
So he had this form of dementia.
I witnessed it.
It was missed a diagnosis.
Parkinson's.
Ah,
and I,
I witnessed this eye witnesses
processing reality completely different
than the way every body else does.
What causes it?
It's,
um,
I'm not sure if it's a gene or what,
but I mean it is,
sadly,
his brain was riddled with this.
And so when I think about that,
I think about how strong he was.
You know,
you would have like some days,
you'd have a lot of days where he was
doing kind of ocd stuff and processing
things incorrectly,
but then you'd have a day where he was
back.
So you'd go,
oh well maybe set a bad day or no,
maybe it's the Parkinson's drugs and
they've got to get those dialed in.
You know,
he had,
he was going to doctors use in therapy,
he was doing,
and it just,
the only reason I talk about that this
is his brain was giving him
misinformation,
completeness,
Information.
And I don't if some people die from
depression and uh,
and my heart goes out to them,
but that's not what killed him.
He,
he,
he really was getting misinformation
from his own brain and was suffering
from this disease.
So I just put that out there because I
have folks know that we were friends in
there.
They'll ask me about it and,
and,
and I would like a spotlight put on the
disease.
That actually in my mind was what was
responsible for his demise.
Cause you know,
a lot of people say,
did he ever talk about suicide?
I go,
what comics?
We talked about suicide for 33 years.
Sometimes we talk about other shit,
you know,
hey,
congratulations on the ASCA.
Oh thank you.
How would you do it?
I don't know.
I think a car,
you know,
but I just say that because he fought,
that's what we do.
I don't know about you,
but a comic,
that's what we do.
We fight depression.
Things don't add up.
It doesn't,
this world doesn't seem right.
And we go out and we spew about it and I
feel better on a selfish level.
I don't really give a rat's ass,
you know,
I vent and I feel like better.
And,
and,
and he fought it.
And that wasn't,
it wasn't depression.
It wasn't career.
It wasn't,
you know,
he'd been sober most of his adult life,
so,
so it's very disturbing to me that a lot
of people were trying to attribute all
sorts of reasons for why he did it.
And even there was a lot of like,
um,
well that's the main things.
Rights groups that were attributing it
to,
uh,
his divorce settlements,
brother.
Yeah.
There was a whole thing where this guy
was doing this video and I even talked
to them about it.
It's,
he had,
uh,
the disease.
He had a disease that caused dementia
that I witnessed.
I didn't have anybody.
I talked to him more,
you know,
I talked to him and text and every day I
didn't have a buddy that I talked to him
more.
So just to be it,
it wasn't a divorce,
it wasn't his family,
wasn't it?
We have the same agent.
So like when this guy was saying,
well,
this is one of the reason why it pissed
me off because this guy was saying that,
you know,
he's in financial ruins.
Like,
no,
he wasn't.
No,
he was wealthy.
Yeah.
And also it's,
it's,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
no one wants to,
uh,
because as human beings,
we're trying to make sense of,
of,
of one why,
why that happened and why that happened
in my opinion,
which is right.
What's his brain was with no more than
you,
it was,
his brain was getting,
uh,
misinformation and he was processing
reality completely wrong.
I mean,
I,
I won't go into details,
but I did witness him thinking things
that weren't real were happening to me
in the middle of the night.
And that's the other thing,
like people say,
oh,
he wasn't in the same bedroom as his
wife.
It's like,
yeah,
because he was having seizures and he
didn't like to wake her up.
Oh God.
It's not a of somebody not getting
along.
I didn't mean to get so personal.
They don't mean it.
And I don't mean to talk about about
his,
uh,
his home life because you know,
Susan's a wonderful Gal and,
and,
and it's just sad,
you know?
No,
it's awful.
That's the,
one of the scariest things is I'm
talking to someone who's,
whether it's a loved one,
a father,
mother that's losing their grip.
And I think people were s they were
courteous to a point,
but I don't think they take his,
his kids and the consideration and
friends and people worked with him for
all these years.
And I guess I can't expect them to,
you know,
I mean I'm sure I've taken shots at
people when they pass away,
but it's just,
it's like people would come up and they
go,
did you hear?
What did you,
what rush limbaugh said?
And I'd be like,
I don't care.
What were some of the says?
I'm dealing with people who dealt with
them on a daily basis.
Let me ask you this,
what is it?
What is this impulse that people have to
denigrate people right after they die?
It's almost like everyone else is,
everyone else is talking about that.
Like I saw a lot of that with prince
when it was revealed that prince was
suffering through opiate addiction.
Yeah.
And I was like,
well there was like gene Simmons said
some crazy shit and he had to apologize
and I'd seen some other people say it
too.
But what it's almost like it's a crunch,
a contrarian thing.
Like everyone else is saying,
oh yeah,
we lost his genius.
Well you get heat from it.
And I'm sure in Gene Simmons is,
you know,
I'm sure there's a jealousy thing,
but you say,
look,
I used to say outrageous things about
people and this bomb would go off and I
would get,
I would get some heat and now I get some
buzz and I stopped doing that.
I made a decision,
you know,
realizing that these weren't just a
harmless things I was saying.
Right,
right,
right.
You just,
yeah.
Yeah.
You know,
it was,
yeah.
Cause there are a lot of that when Kurt
cobain died too.
But you know,
and that's the W W W W I wasn't best
these with Kurt,
but I did know him.
I toured with Nirvana,
Kurt,
like my standup and asked me to go on
the road with them.
I did a bunch of days then we talked
about it.
But,
but I,
I mean it wasn't like the situation was
wrong,
but,
but I did have times in my life where I
spent hours with Kurt when the o
announce sitting around talking and
laughing,
you know,
um,
I don't know why we want to do that.
I think,
I think we try to make sense of it.
I think we tried to make sense of it,
I think.
I think that's where a lot of
conspiracies come from.
I think when when someone who's in our
mind reach the American dream and then
they die or look or come or take their
life or overdose,
we have to say,
well,
they had it all and that's what we
believe is the ultimate fulfillment and
happiness.
You know,
America is the People's Republic of
spring break.
You know,
where no one's pursuing fulfillment.
Everyone's pursuing happiness.
You know,
there's two different things.
I'm really fulfilled.
Am I happy?
Am I laughing all day?
Am I know?
But you're happy sometimes I'm happy.
A lot of the time I've never not talk.
Like if I didn't know that you're this
nuance guy that's very thoughtful and
you have a lot of opinions and you're
always considering all answered.
If I just took,
like if I tried to form a view of you
based on you and I talking,
we're always laughing.
Yeah.
I would say bobcat.
So jolly.
Every time we talk to them,
it's like laughs and hugs and,
but it is true and it's,
and it's uh,
uh,
cause we never see each other before
noon,
first of all.
But it's a,
it's a,
it's a daily reprieve.
It's a daily decision.
You know,
I get up,
the squirrels are up before I do and I,
and I beat him down and then it turns
and when I'm directing on a set,
I'm like,
I can react and fear or I can just sit
here for a second or two in.
It all usually works out.
Very rarely do I have to say no.
Go Man,
this is,
you just sit there.
I think so much of show business,
everything's based on fear and people
thinking someone's going to say you
screwed up or you didn't do it right or
you didn't get extra takes and all that
stuff.
But man,
my job is really not to to freak out.
Hmm.
I really happy right now.
Well that's beautiful,
man.
I think you're doing some awesome work.
I really do.
I have to quit.
You know,
because that's again,
that's very an American.
You never quit.
Never give up.
It's like quit,
quit,
quit.
And then until you end up someplace
where you don't want to leave,
and that's what I've done.
Quit everything.
That doesn't feel right.
That doesn't,
you know,
when,
when I made the decision not to go on
auditions,
it was scary and it became the best
thing that ever happened to me.
All of a sudden I'm freed up and I'm
writing screenplays and I'm doing,
you know,
it's like,
what am I trying to get on?
You know,
who's your daddy or whatever the fuck.
You know what I mean?
A burden the hand or whatever the fuck.
You know,
what am I doing?
What am I doing?
You know,
but,
but you find your voice,
you know,
I mean,
it's interesting now to,
to see the stuff you're doing.
And the funny thing to me is like
someone in interviews and cause I make
about a movie every year,
a year and a half.
And they're like,
so,
so what is the,
you know,
what is,
who is,
who are you competing with?
What other filmmaker you competing with
them?
I'm like,
I'm competing with the grim fucking
reaper.
I just figured this out like 10 years
ago.
What I want to do,
you know?
That's,
that's,
that's what motivates me.
I got a hold of you now.
I'm 53 I'll be 54 and so like when you
run,
you hit 40 like Uga,
this father fucking things ticking.
Oh Man.
You know,
and I,
I write a lot and I write screenplays
that'll never get made,
but I just ride them to get up out of
me,
you know?
And that's,
and that's what,
that's what it's about really.
It's about whatever it is that you're
compelled to do that you can do that
you're talented at,
and then pursuing that and just fuck all
the rest of it,
you know?
And I see it immediately here with say
this,
and they think that,
well,
it's easy for you guys.
You know,
you,
you had this other career and all this
stuff.
It's like,
no,
not really.
I mean,
I come with baggage.
Do you think the first movie I sent the
Sundance people didn't go?
You know what I mean?
Right,
right.
Hey Zed from police academy,
we made a movie,
let's watch this.
You know what I mean?
So,
so sure.
We have a lot of of foot,
you know,
we have a lot of things are easier on
some ways,
but then there's baggage.
Yeah,
well that's just,
I guess that's with anybody that's been
in the public eye for a long period of
time,
especially again,
a guy like you,
that's a nuance guy.
There's a lot going on.
There's,
there's uh,
there's the happy stuff and there's
anger and there's silly shit and there's
mockery and then there's like really
important points that you want to make,
you know?
And then there's mistakes and there's
impulses and we've all met those.
Yeah.
But that's,
that's the best part.
Yeah.
I don't know.
If I was on a set and,
and,
and I felt people weren't having an
enjoyable time,
it would,
not that it needs to be a party,
but if you know,
people felt compromised,
it would really bother me.
Oh,
for sure.
Look if you were having an actor to a
part that they just really didn't
believe in and thought the piece was
paying off the process.
Got It.
Was was unpleasant.
You know,
I mean,
my sets are usually pretty ridiculous,
you know,
I'm the one that's probably
internalizing,
but it's very,
you know,
I can't explain it.
Like,
um,
like when I was on Kimmel,
you know,
I remember once I,
I spent $8,000 and I bought
10 tons of snow and put it in the
parking lot for Christmas and Jimmy
looks at the window,
it goes,
what does that,
what does that Disney have a,
no,
I bought snow for everybody.
It's like go play and stole my God.
We made,
we made,
we went sledding,
we made ramps.
We had the hugest snowball fight.
You know,
life's short.
I remember once everybody wanted to kill
each other,
so I rented one of those giant balloon
bounces and you know,
everybody just bounced around and it was
nobody,
there was no pressure on the set
anymore.
Do you,
did you like doing that show or was it
just really,
I really,
I really liked it a lot and then,
then I actually loved it and then when I
started to realize I was,
uh,
honestly,
I'll be really honest right now when I
started to feel like I was starting to
phone it in,
I was like going,
this is not fair to my friend Brian who
I love.
I love him.
Oh,
we do a lot of directions,
right?
You did.
Well,
I ran into,
in New York when you were doing the
Chappelle show,
worked on Chappelle the very first
episode.
It,
well,
I would work at the beginning.
Uh,
Dave Chappelle's not crazy.
That's the other thing that drives me
nuts,
you know,
cause he walked away,
but I saw those people micromanage him
and drive him nuts.
They were so rude.
Not,
there's not crazy.
He's a friend of mine.
I love Dave.
He's a very,
very brilliant guy.
Yeah.
I very smart and aware.
And how's the Kahunas to do what you
said,
to quit,
to walk away from 50 million bucks.
I'm uncomfortable saying this story,
but I don't know,
he's just trying to use,
cause I,
I know the semantics of the language,
I'll just say what happened.
People can make whatever.
But I was,
I was directing the show and white
comedy central executives came down and
asked me,
they said,
can you tell Dave not the same nigger so
much?
And I said,
Dave,
the white comedy central executives in
front of him so much that goes Bobcat
Push Pasha,
what did you say?
It was really weird and awkward and then
they left.
Like I intentionally thought,
well this will be embarrassing for them.
This is exactly what you told me.
Oh good.
Cause cause yeah,
I don't think I've ever come forward
that story,
but yeah,
I'm the,
I'm witness to that insanity.
As the show became more and more
successful,
apparently what had happened was
advertisers were skittish about being
involved,
even though,
even though it's gangbusters ratings,
they still were like,
he's keeps saying the n word.
Toyota doesn't really want to be
involved with the n word.
We don't know what to do.
Um,
so,
um,
you know,
they took,
in my opinion,
the greatest sketch comedy show of all
time.
I don't think there's anything that
comes close.
So I think it was two years.
So one of my greatest accomplishments as
an actor,
cause I don't really like much what I
did except for news radio,
but one of the greatest accomplishments
mean he's like,
I feel like I was on the greatest show
of all time.
I did a couple sketches on the greatest
show of all time.
I really think that show was the all
time most innovative and hilarious
sketch comedy show ever from the haters
ball.
Like the haters convention to the Black
Blind.
A waste of white supremacist too.
I mean you could go down the list of the
Rick James and draft the racial draft.
Yeah.
I mean he had so many killer,
killer,
killer bits.
There were just,
it was so original.
He's brilliant.
Well that's one of the most offensive
things about what's going on now.
Like there's so much rehashed and
regenerated and just did this take like
a script,
a take a sketch from mad TV and they
sorta rework it and spit it out today on
some new show and it's fucking gross.
I mean,
that's what you're seeing.
what Amy Schumer's getting accused of,
you know,
what you're seeing over and over again
and they keep showing these sketches.
Well here was a sketch that was on mad
TV.
Here's a sketchup was on this,
here was the sketches that he never saw
that with Chappelle was Chapelle.
All those sketches were unique and
unusual.
Yeah.
And it was also kind of a,
the funny thing was also in the editing
process,
uh,
following the ball,
like,
like
we would discover stuff that was just
funny in the in,
you know,
I can't explain it.
It's like we're cutting this a
Mitsubishi commercial and the woman
there,
her breasts came out during the filming
and not in this part of this grip.
I could dave just see that and you just
see Dave's eyes go right.
Then he busted himself on the,
during the ramp around,
showed what he done.
That's a little bit beautiful.
It was beautiful because he was busted.
And so,
yeah,
I,
uh,
yeah,
it was really weird for him to be,
it just drives me nuts when people act
like he's crazy.
Cause I think he's super sane in a
brilliant and really nice or whatever.
A black guy goes to Africa and you go,
oh,
he's fucking lost it.
Right,
right.
What does he do when he went to Africa
to try to find peace?
Jesus Christ,
they offered them 50 million bucks and
he went to Africa.
He lost his mind and lost his fucking
month.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the thing that,
uh,
that people,
yeah,
when you,
again,
when I was saying,
you know,
fulfillment versus,
this idea of just having a 24 hour
orgasm and,
you know,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
Wait,
we don't pursue being fulfilled,
which is the whole jam.
Right?
Well,
it's a tricky little dance because,
cause we have to pay bills and we have
to raise their kids and we have to be
responsible.
But,
but,
uh,
you know this,
every time you take that leap,
every time you go,
well,
this is really scary way.
Every time it pays off.
I've never taken the leap.
I've taken leaps why I did what I
thought people wanted or I thought might
work or might be successful.
That always works terribly.
But I've just said,
I've got to tell this story because this
is the story that I'm interested right
now that's always paid off.
How's it paid off?
Is it,
I might do my rich and my this and that.
No,
but you know,
unfulfilled.
So I sit there and I connect with a
small group of people in that.
That's pretty amazing.
Beautiful.
That's it.
The end can either buddy bobcat call
with lettuce,
gentlemen,
give it up.
Give it up.
Thanks brother.
Thank you.
There's a lot of fun,
man.
Thank God we did it.
That was great.
And we ended with the headphones on.
We kept him on.
Is this thing still recording?
Gary Johnson tomorrow.
Presidential candidate Gary Johnson 9:00
AM.
See a fox.
Yeah.